mais il est hélas connu notre pays a
connu une baisse du niveau général ces
dernières décennies un élève de 4e de
2018 avait le niveau d'un élève de 5e de
1995 en 23 ans c'est un an qui a été
perdu quand on regarde aujourd'hui les
évaluations nombreuses qui sont
réalisées chaque année les évaluations
nationales que nous devons à l'action de
JeanMichel blanqu je dois le dire nous
voyons qu'un élève sur 3 qui rentre en
6e ne sait pas lire écrire et compter
correctement
nous voyons que un élève sur de en
classe de 6e ne sait pas dire combien il
y a de quart d'heure dans 3/4 d'heure
nous voyons que à l'occasion du brevet
des collèges pour les élèves de 3e 25 %
d'entre eux ont moins de 4/ 20 en
mathématiques au brevet des collèges le
4/ 20 étant la note la plus distribuée
en mathématique au brevets des collèges
ce retard s'accumule et se se et se
perpétue tout au long de la scolarité
c'est donc dès les premières années
qu'il nous faut agir nous savons av pour
la maîtrise des savoirs fondamentaux
c'est dès le début de la scolarité que
tout se joue c'est dès le début que l'on
peut éviter un décrochage qui reste un
échec pour tous c'est dès le début qu'il
nous faut replacer au cœur de l'école la
notion d'exigence l'exigence sans
laquelle il n'y a ni excellence ni
égalité des chances dans notre école
républicaine pour cela mon ministère
dispose de moyens historiques le projet
de loi de finances pour 2024 que vous
aurez examiné dans les prochaines
semaines prévoit une augmentation
inédite du premier budget de la Nation
je vais pas rentrer dans le détail
puisqu'on aura une audition dédié mais
simplement pour donner un chiffre que
j'ai donné tout à l'heure aux questions
d'actualité au gouvernement depuis 2017
l'école a perdu 300000 élèves du fait de
la démographie le budget a augmenté de
30 %. 300000 élèves de moins 30 % de
budget en plus ça ne s'est jamais vu
dans les dernières décennies dans le
quinquena qui s'ouvre l'école perdra
autour de 400000 élèves du fait de la
démographie qui doit évidemment nous
préoccuper une question a lieu tout à
l'heure sur le sujet et le budget
continuera à augmenter nous avons
amélioré le taux d'encadrement ces
dernières années nous allons allons
continuer à l'améliorer en 2024 ce ces
budgets et ces moyens supplémentaires
nous permettent de poursuivre un certain
nombre de chantier d'achever à la
rentrée 2024 le dédoublement des classes
de grandes sections de maternelle en Rep
et REP plus ce qui permettra à notre
pays d'enseigner à 500000 élèves en
grandes section CP et CE1 dans des
classes dédoublées précisément là où
nous devons briser les inégalités de
destin de poursuivre l'effort d'accueil
dès 2 ans en très petite section avec 60
dispositifs supplémentaires en quartier
politique de la ville soit une
augmentation de 50 % de renforcer
l'apprentissage de la lecture et la
pratique de l'écriture dès le CP et tout
au long de l'école élémentaire il y a
urgence c'est pourquoi nous renforçons
aussi la lecture de textes longs dès le
CM1 j'ai eu l'occasion de l'annoncer
l'écriture d'au moins un texte par
semaine en CM2 et les stages de réussite
durant les vacances scolaires dans le
cadre du dispositif école ouverte dont
300000 élèves ont bénéficié l'an dernier
les nouvelles évaluations nationales en
CM1 qui se sont déroulées ces dernières
semaines et dont les résultats sont en
cours de consolidation nous permettront
également d'identifier les besoins de
chaque élève pour mieux y répondre enfin
en 6e cela nous permet de déployer des
SEP rentrées une heure de plus par
semaine en français et en mathématiques
par groupe d'élèves réparti par besoin
parallèlement aux enseignements aux
classes entières pour des cours de
soutien ou d'approfondissement dans ces
matières fondamentales c'est la clé de
même que la généralisation des devoirs
faits en 6e qui permettent en moyenne
2h30 par semaine de soutien aux élèves
et je soulligne ici que ce sont les
élèves de REP et REP plus qui en
bénéficient le plus au lycée le
rétablissement dans le Tron commun de la
première générale d'unh30 obligatoire de
mathématique par semaine il faut avoir
la lucidité là aussi de le reconnaître
supprimer les mathématiques du Tron
commun a été une erreur de la même façon
positionner les épreuves de spécialité
du baccalauréat général et technologique
en mars n'était pas une bonne idée on
l'a vu cette année avec une très forte
augmentation de l'absentéisme et
globalement de la démotivation des
élèves après les épreuves de spécialité
en mars puisqueune grande partie d'entre
eux savaient à ce moment-là qu'ils
avaient leur B baccalauréat avec les
notes des épreuves de spécialité et le
contrôle continu nous avons la lucidité
de le reconnaître et je le crois le
pragmatisme d'y répondre c'est pour
répondre à votre question sur cette
décision que j'ai eu à prendre dès ma
nomination vous le savez j'ai fait le
choix non seulement après avoir échanger
avec les organisations syndicales et les
représentants des parents d'élèves et
des personnels de rétablir ces épreuves
en juin mais j'en ai profité pour
réaffirmer que l'année scolaire doit
aller jusqu'au bout du mois de juin et
que la reconquête du mois de juin est
une priorité absolue nous avons donc
positionné les épreuves assez tard dans
le mois de juin de sorte que dans les
deux premières semaines de juin tous les
élèves du lycée auront cours que dans la
deuxème quinzaine de juin il y aura les
premières et les terminales en épreuve
et que les élèves de Seconde réaliseront
un stage en entreprise en administration
en association ce qui veut dire que tous
les élèves seront mobilisés jusqu'à la
fin du mois de juin de la même manière
j'ai décidé de positionner les épreuves
du brevet des collèges le plus loin que
ce n'a jamais été au mois de juillet ça
a très rarement été euh au mois de
juillet pour que les élèves du collège
restent en cours jusqu'à la fin du mois
de juin on ne peut pas ambitionner
d'élever le niveau en acceptant que
l'année scolaire s'arrête pour des
élèves dès la fin du mois de mai dans la
voie professionnelle la réforme que nous
engageons en cette rentrée augmentera
d'un milliard d'euros les moyens des
lycées professionnels permettra de
développer les périodes de formation des
élèves en milieu professionnel ces
stages seront désormais gratifiés de 50
à 100 € par semaine ça permettra de
déployer des cours en petits effectifs
dans les enseignements généraux mais
aussi de créer de nouvelles options pour
les lycéens professionnels avec des
cours d'entrepreneuriat des cours de
codage ou des langues vivantes pour
poursuivre cette bataille des savoirs
j'ai annoncé la semaine dernière la mise
en place d'une mission avec des recteurs
des chercheurs des inspecteurs de
l'éducation nationale des professeurs et
d'autres personnels de terrain qui me
remettront leurs conclusions d'ici la
fin de l'année je le redis il y a
urgence pour élever le niveau et lutter
contre tous les déterminismes nous
aurons je l'espère l'occasion d'échanger
sur cette mission et ces recommandations
fondamentales pour l'avenir de notre
pays vouloir élever le niveau c'est
évidemment aussi lutter contre les cours
perdus pour les élèves l'an dernier il y
a 15 millions d'heures de cours qui
n'ont pas été honorés pour les élèves 15
millions d'heures d'absence non remplacé
on peut pas ambitionner d'élever le
niveau avec 15 millions d'heures de
cours perdu sur une année j'ai fait de
ce sujet une priorité sur ces 15
millions d'heur perdu la moitié sont lié
à l'organisation de notre système et
donc il faut éviter les absences
évitables en repositionnant les épreuves
de spécialité du mois de mars Au mois de
juin nous récupérons des heures qui
étaient perdu à cause de l'organisation
des examens j'ai assumé j'assume le
choix de positionner désormais la
formation continue des enseignants en
dehors du temps de classe je dis pas en
dehors du temps scolaire et uniquement
sur les vacances mais en tout cas en
dehors du temps de classe c'est près de
2 millions d'heures de cours l'an
dernier qui ont été perdu du fait de
temps de formation des enseignants sur
le temps de la classe pour ce qui est
des sens qu'on ne peut pas éviter il y
en aura évidemment toujours dans une
administration 1200000 agents il nous
faut améliorer notre capacité de
remplacement c'est donc pour répondre à
votre deuxè question sur le pacte
enseignant puisque vous savez le pacte
vise à mieux rémunérer mieux soutenir
les les enseignants qui s'engagent
notamment dans le remplacement de courte
durée il y en a déjà beaucoup qui
s'engageaient dans le remplacement de
courte durée ces années précédentes en
heures supplémentaires ils seront
désormais rémunérés 50 % de plus pour
ces missions qu'ils effectuaient déjà
jusqu'à l'année dernière un enseignant
qui faisait du remplacement de courte
durée était rémunéré je crois 41 € brut
de l'heure avec le PACT enseignant ça
passe à 70 € brut de l'heure d'
augmentation très importante qui a
vocation à ce qu'il y ait évidemment
davantage de remplacement pour ces cours
qui sont euh sinon perdus pour pour les
élèves vous m'interrogiez sur la le
déploiement du PACT j'ai eu l'occasion
de communiquer sur des premiers chiffres
mais qui sont vraiment très
préliminaires parce qu'ils datent de la
fin du mois de septembre plutôt la deè
début de la deuxième moitié de septembre
que toutes les académies n'ont pas pu
nous les faire remonter et que vous le
savez le recours au Pact dépend beaucoup
des protocoles sur le remplacement signé
dans chaque établissement et que tous
les établissements n'avaient pas signé
leur protocole et pourtant un enseignant
sur quat s'est engagé dans le PACT c'est
même un sur TR au collège et un sur TR
au lycée professionnel ce qui est quand
même assez loin des prévision parfois on
va dire terrible qui était faite
notamment par certains obser ou
certaines organisations syndicales moi
je veux les remercier évidemment de
s'être engagé dans le pacte enseignant
j'aurai l'occasion d'avoir un nouveau
bilan chiffré sur le pacte au retour des
vacances de la tousin et évidemment je
répondrai aux questions que vous aurez
sur ce sujet ma deuxième priorité c'est
de bâtir une école des droits et devoirs
c'est d'abord un devoir de
reconnaissance que nous avons et que
j'ai comme ministre vis-à-vis de tous
ceux qui font vivre l'école cela passe
en grande partie par la rémunération en
la matière là aussi nous tenons nos
engagements en cette rentrée les
professeurs sont rémunérés entre 125 et
250 € nets de plus par mois qu'à la
rentrée précédente septembre 2022
septembre 2023 et ce sans conditions il
y a eu deux revalorisations du point
d'indice une revalorisation socle en
cette rentrée ça fait entre 125 et 250 €
nets de plus par mois entre septembre 22
et septembre 23 pour les professeurs
néotitulaires qui démarrent dans
l'enseignement ils sont désormais
rémunérés 2100 € nets par mois c'est
même 2400 so 66 € en Rep plus avec ces
revalorisations inédites nous
effaçons en grande partie une génération
de déclassement salarial pour nos
professeurs et nous revenons exprimer en
point de Smic à un niveau de
rémunération supérieur par rapport à
celui de l'an 2000 c'est la plus forte
augmentation de salaire dans l'éducation
nationale depuis des décennies j'entends
évidemment qu'il y a en grande partie du
rattrapage justement de ces dernières
décennies j'entends que pour un certain
nombre d'enseignants c'est encore
difficile mais enfin il me semble
important de reconnaître qu'il n'y a pas
eu d'équival ces 30 dernières années
d'augmentation salariale dans
l'éducation nationale que ce que nous
avons fait c'est depuis la réélection du
président de la République depuis la
réélection du président en 2022
entre mi-2022 et janvier 2024 puisque
vous savez qu'il y a une dernière mesure
en janvier 2024 avec l'injection de 5
point d'indice majorés pour tous les
fonctionnaires mais qui bénéficiera
aussi au enseignants si on met bout à
bout ces mesures entre avril 2022 et
janvier 2024 c'est plus 11 % au global
en moyenne de revalorisation ce devoir
de reconnaissance nous le devons
également aux aesh qui accompagnent
chaque jour les élèves en situation de
handicap dans leur scolarité en cette
rentrée plus de la moitié des aesh sont
désormais en CDI ce qui marque notre
volonté forte de déprécariser ce métier
l'an dernier on était à peine en dessous
de 30 % d'AES en CDI par ailleurs toute
bénéficie d'une revalorisation de 10 à
13 %. évidemment si on veut
structurellement et véritablement
améliorer la rémunération des aesh c'est
sur le temps de travail qu'il faut jouer
si vous êtes à 24 heur maximum par
semaine pour améliorer votre
rémunération il faut évidemment
augmenter le volume horaire c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous travaillons
évidemment avec les collectivités
locales sur le temps périscolaire nous
travaillons aussi dans les suites de la
Conférence nationale du handicap sur des
missions supplémentaires qui pourrai
être confié aux aesh pour leur permettre
d'avoir un temps complet et donc une
meilleure rémunération mais nous
attendons pas ce travail pour faire une
revalorisation nous poursuivons
également l'effort de recrutement à
l'heure où je vous parle nos effectifs
et nos école compte 15000 AES de plus
qu'à la rentrée 2022 l'école des droits
et devoirs c'est aussi le respect de
l'autorité du maître et de l'autorité
des savoirs c'est le respect des
principes les plus élémentaires de notre
République comme la laïcité ces derniers
mois nous le savons les atteintes à la
laïcité s'était développé à un rythme
inquiétant que cela concerne la
contestation des enseignements en
histoire géographie en SVT ou dans
d'autres disciplines ou bien sûr le port
de tenue non conforme à la loi de 2004
vous le savez j'ai assumé une une
décision importante au moment de ma
nomination une décision importante mais
qui en réalité n'aurait pas dû être vécu
comme telle puisqu'il s'agit simplement
de décider d'appliquer la loi la loi de
2004 ce qu' a confirmé le Conseil d'État
dans son avis qui a été remis suite aux
référés qui ont été conduits par
certaines associations sur ma décision
le Conseil d'État a confirmé que je ne
faisais qu'appliquer la loi de 2004 vous
m'avez interrogé monsieur le Président
sur la manière dont cette mesure s'est
appliquée je suis je le dis très
satisfait de la manière dont cette
mesure a été
appliquée nous avons eu sur la première
semaine de la rentrée scolaire autour
d'un millier de contestations de la
règle par des élèves ce qui est peu par
rapport au nombre de tenu non conformes
qui étaient porté l'année dernière ce
qui montre qu'une grande partie des
élèves concernés s'était conformé à la
règle pour le jour de la rentrée et
surtout dans la quasi totalité des cas
nous sommes parvenus par la pédagogie et
le dialogue à régler ces situations et
moi je veux vraiment rendre hommage aux
chefs d'établissement à leurs équipes
aux équipes laïité valeur de la
République des rectorats qui étaient au
côté des chefs d'établissement pour
engager ce dialogue et cette pédagogie
avec les élèves et les familles pour moi
ça montre que quand il y a de la
pédagogie du dialogue bref de l'humain
on arrive à gérer des situations tendues
et c'est pour moi un enseignement y
compris que je porte pour la question du
harcèlement scolaire ma troisème
priorité c'est enfin de construire une
école qui émancipe et qui rend heureux
s'émancipé c'est pour nos élèves la
chance d'acquérir une autonomie d'esprit
un esprit critique une ouverture
intellectuelle à tous les savoir et au
monde cette émancipation passe d'abord
par l'enseignement des humanités et de
la culture générale c'est pourquoi nous
étendons à tous les collégiens l'accès
aux passculture alors que plus de la
moitié des élèves de 4e et de 3e ont pu
bénéficier l'an passé d'une activité à
ce titre visiter un musée avec un guide
conférencier assister à une
représentation au théâtre pratiquer un
instrument de musique
autant de découvertes et de pratiques
qui font l'éducation artistique et
culturelle de notre jeunesse et que nous
développons en cette rentrée encore
grâce à l'extension du passeculture
collectif à l'école nous allons
également refonder pour la rentrée
prochaine l'enseignement moral et
civique j'y tiens tout particulièrement
l'école doit non seulement élever le
niveau mais former des républicains pour
cela mon prédécesseur a saisi le Conseil
supérieur des programmes qui me rendra
ses propositions d'ici la fin de l'année
je veillai tout particulièrement à la
place de nos institutions dans cette
enseignement un enseignement de la
laïcité et je sais Monsieur le Président
que la mission que vous conduisez sera
très utile là aussi pour enrichir ce
travail là avec le sujet de la BAA
évidemment on n pas réglé tous les
sujets d'application de la laïcité à
l'école loin de là je rappelle que dans
les récentes études encore un enseignant
sur deux déclare s'autocensuré notamment
pour des raisons de contestation de la
laïcité dois donc poursuivre et
j'attends beaucoup de la mission qui est
conduite par les sénatrices et les
sénateurs sur ce sujet je veux avancer
aussi sur l'éducation aux médias et à
l'information dont nous percevons chaque
jour l'utilité face au tentation de
l'instantané et de l'immédiateté qui ne
remplaceront jamais l'esprit critique et
le débat éclairé l'objectif est que dès
la rentrée prochaine nous puissions
doubler le temps dédié à l'enseignement
moral et civique dès la 5e enfin je ne
saurais parler des droits et devoirs
d'une école qui rend heureux sans parler
du droit absolu pour chaque élève de la
République d'être en paix à l'école oui
le devoir du politique est de garantir à
chaque élève une scolarité sereine je
veux bien sûr parler du fléo que
représente le harcèlement scolaire qui a
déjà fait souffrir trop de nos enfants
et de leurs familles parfois jusqu'à
l'irréparable chaque élève a le droit à
la parole chaque élève a le droit à
l'écoute chaque élève a le droit d'être
protégé voilà pourquoi le gouvernement
et avec lui j'en suis sûr une très large
majorité des membres du Parlement font
de la lutte contre le harcèlement
scolaire et le cyberhcèlement une cause
absolument prioritaire pour notre école
j'en ai fait en tout cas ma grande cause
pour l'école et je n'accepterai pas
qu'on oppose cette priorité là aux
autres que j'ai évoqué précédemment on
peut pas imaginer élever le niveau si on
a des centaines de milliers ou des
millions d'élèves qui sont malheureux à
l'école quand vous êtes harcelé le
harcèlement envahit totalement votre
esprit il n'y a plus de place pour autre
chose il y a plus de place pour les
apprentissages agir pour le bonheur des
élèves à l'école c'est aussi agir pour
élever le niveau parce qu'on leur permet
d'étudier et d'apprendre en
paix je l'ai dit nous devons
profondément nous remettre en question
sur ce sujet-là y compris dans les
pratiques qui ont pu exister dès cet été
j'ai publié un décret pour que désormais
ce soient les élèves harceleurs et non
les élèves harcelés qui soient contraint
de changer d'établissement dès cette
rentrée nous avons étendu le programme
phare pour que 100 % de nos écoles
collèges et lycées prennent pleinement
leur part à une démarche de prévention
de détection et de résolution de chaque
situation individuelle nous devons
remettre de l'écoute et de l'humain à
tous les étages des rectorats à nos
établissements dans chacune de nos
écoles dans chacun de nos collèges et
chacun de nos lycées de l'humain on ne
luttera pas contre le harcèlement avec
des plans ou avec des circulaires nous
réussirons et j'ai vu au Danemark mais
aussi dans certaines écoles de notre
pays de très belles réussites pour faire
reculer le harcèlement nous réussirons
si nous changeons profondément de
culture face au harcèlement et si nous
nous en donnons les moyens les décisions
que nous avons présenté avec la première
ministre il y a quelques jours vise à
traduire ce changement de culture ça
passe évidemment par la pour suite du
renforcement de la formation des
personnels par la sensibilisation des
élèves et des parents par le
renforcement des moyens humains dans les
académies et la mise en place d'équipe
d'intervention
dédié le 9 novembre prochain se tiendra
dans tous nos établissements la journée
non au harcèlement et pour la première
fois dans notre histoire un temps dédié
sera consacré dans chaque salle de
classe à la prévention et au recueil de
la parole par ailleurs internet et les
réseaux sociaux ne doivent plus demeurer
des zones de non droit où nos enfants
naviguent en insécurité des formes de
cours d'école sans règles ni
supervisation par aucun adulte à cet
égard je me réjouis euh des amendements
adoptés par vos collègues députés dans
le cadre du projet de loi visant à
sécuriser et réguler l'espace numérique
ces amendements qui ont été adoptés il y
a quelques minutes à l'Assemblée
nationale permettront aux juges
d'interdire à l'élève harceleur l'accès
aux réseaux sociaux pour une durée
jusqu'à 6 mois sans préjuger de l'issue
de la navette parlementaire j'ai la
conviction que ces mesures sont de
nature à participer au renforcement de
la lutte contre le cyberhcèlement
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs les Français attendent
beaucoup de leur école et ils ont raison
la libération de la parole que nous
observons ces dernières semaines sur le
harcèlement démontre non seulement
l'urgence à agir mais aussi tous les
progrès que nous pouvons accomplir si
nous sommes unis pour notre école au
fond toutes les priorités de l'agenda
que je viens de vous présenter sont
liées on ne peut pas élever le niveau je
le disais si nos élèves sont malheureux
à l'école on ne peut pas élever le
niveau si nos professeurs sont
malheureux d'enseigner ne retrouvent pas
la fierté et le prestige d'un métier si
indispensable en démocratie on ne peut
pas élever le niveau si on retrouve pas
le sens des principes à commencer par
l'autorité du maître et l'autorité des
savoirs qui permettent le progrès dans
nos sociétés pour conduire toutes ces
transformations je suis convaincu que
nous saurons trouver des points d'accord
dans l'intérêt supérieur du pays et de
sa jeunesse uni pour son école notre
pays n'en sera que plus fort et plus
juste je vous remercie merci Monsieur le
Ministre première série de questions de
notre rapporteur budgétaire Jacques
groperin qui veillera ne pas poser
toutes les questions
entendu
oui j'ai bien compris monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre merci de
votre propos quel programme quel
programme et quel programme j'avais en
son temps lors de lors de d'une audition
avec votre prédécesseur dit à votre
prédécesseur soyez ministre pesz et
cetera je ne doute pas de vos
convictions de vos enthousiasmes de
votre énergie je voudrais tout d'abord
saluer ce qui n'est pas courant de la
part de unee opposition politique mais
d'une opposition en tout cas
républicaine les gestes que vous avez eu
vis-à-vis de cette interdiction que vous
avez proposé et combien de fois nous
l'avons demandé au à votre prédécesseur
l'interdiction donc de la baaya je crois
qu'un moment donné vous avez dit vous
avez assumé je crois que le terme est
bien é assumé la France en tout cas les
Français les chefs d'établissement
l'attendaient et et vous en remercie la
deuxième chose je voudrais aussi vous
féliciter sur votre prise de position
vis-à-vis des courriers vis-à-vis de
Versailles ce sont des gestes qui ne
sont pas anodins parce que les parents
vous écoutent vous entendent et vous
représentez le ministère de l'Éducation
nationale vous représentez aussi quelque
part la França et enfin euh peut-être
aussi vous dire et et dans cette période
singulière tout à l'heure sur les
question d'actualité avec où il y avait
beaucoup de d'émotion la visite ce matin
d'une école juive à sarcell avec le
ministre de l'intérieur c'est un moment
important qui est regardé et c'est grâce
à des moments comme ça que vous pourrez
que vous symbolisez la République mais
vous pourrez aussi à un moment donné
apporter beaucoup de choses à la
République et à are nation qui en ce
moment souffre j'ai entendu je serai pas
trop long parce qu'il y aura d'autres
moments le président nous l'a fort bien
dit tout à l'heure sur le sur sur en
tout cas le financement de de de ce de
votre projet en tout cas de ce projet-
là il y a beaucoup de choses qui ont été
dites mais simplement je voudrais vous
alerter faites attention au niveau de la
communication parce qu'à vouloir trop
communiquer à un moment donné on peut
perturber les uns et les autres on peut
perturber les chef d'établissement on
peut perturber les enseignants on peut
perturber parfois les élèves et et je
comprends votre élan votre enthousiasme
et votre envie parce qu'on vous demande
tellement en même temps que c'est
tellement difficile et que vous avez
envie certainement de tellement bien
faire sur les les trois points remettre
l'aspect l'autorité savoir fondamentaux
on va pas refaire l'histoire sur ce qui
se passe en France mais on aura quand
même un questionnement à voir un jour à
ce qui se passe véritablement en classe
dans la classe mais là il y a quelque
chose qui est de l'ordre du du du pas de
chef d'établissement mais de
l'enseignant et c'est pas toujours
facile de mais véritablement il faudra
se poser la question de ce qui se passe
parce que on a le premier budget on l'a
dit tout à l'heure 100 milliard mais je
crois que un moment donné on peut être
aussi en demande d'autres choses vous
avez dit garantir à chaque élève chaque
jour un prof face à lui ça c'est
fondamental là je le relirai par rapport
à la formation continue lorsque vous
avez 10 15 millions d'heur qui n'avent
qui ne sont pas enseignés dont 10 % dans
le casre de la formation continue vous
proposez que ça soit alors vous faites
la nuance dans le temps scolaire en
dehors de l'écolecole et cetera je crois
que on a bien vu qu'avec la ministre
Belkassem même en posant à un moment
donné une rémunération même en posant
d'autres choses ça n'a pas marché
comment vous allez inciter les
enseignants inciter j'ai pas dit obligé
à pouvoir fonctionner dans le cadre en
tout cas de faire cette formation
continue en sachant que les enseignants
en France parce que la priorité c'est le
français les mathématiques les
enseignants du français ont deux fois
moins de formation continue que leurs
collègues de l'OCDE vous n avez parlé
faire une une école ou un lieu où chaque
enfant puisse être heureux et la lutre
de harcellement que N ne concurrenz pas
avec le reste c'est fondamental mais euh
je voudrais faire référence à la
médecine scolaire médecine scolaire il y
a une concurrence très forte vis-à-vis
euh euh de d'autres organismes et on le
voit bien dans l' département du dou il
y a 15 emplois ETP et il y a a que cinq
qui sont en tout cas occupés quand je
dis médecine scolaire c'est aussi
infirmier et il participe aussi au
repérage vis-à-vis du harcèlement la
souffrance et cetera et cetera donc ce
sont des choses qui qui me semblent
fondamental euh vous nous avez parlé
également euh des semaines entrepris
pour les élèves de seconde et cetera
alors ça c'est une période aussi qui est
à cheval entre les périodes du SNU
faisons attention le SNU c'est une
priorité du président de la République
comment vous allez l'organiser pour qu'
moment donné on puisse gérer cela parce
qu'il nous paraît important et ces
annonces ont fait qu' moment donné il y
a une crise pas une crise mais ça crée
des attentes chez les
personnelséducation national ça crée des
attentes chez les entreprises et ça
prise qu' un moment donné de poser
problème et enfin sur le pacte
d'enseignement j'en ai parlé moi
j'aimerais vous parler de l'excellent
rapport et surtout proposition de loi de
notre excellent collègue Max Brisson
pouréco la liberté l'égalité été des
Chan all cité dans tout ce que vous
présentez aujourd'hui dans tout ce que
vous proposez il y a des pistes qui sont
intéressantes alors je vais pas prendre
l'article 4 sur l'article 3 sur sur les
dérogations modalités d'affectation des
enseignants mais pour qu'un enseignant
fonctionne bien et puiss efficace fa
qu'il se sente bien mais l'article 4 qui
est la création des écoles supérieures
du professeurat des écoles parce qu'il y
a un vrai problème de la formation et je
pense que redonner à l'éducation
nationale en tout cas la formation
qu'elle reprenne en main cette formation
du premier degré avec cette création des
écoles supérieures du professeur des
écoles ça pourrait être aussi un chemin
que vous pourrez prendre pour
pouvoir pas conclure mais en tout cas
engager dans ce vaste projet cette
vaste en tout cas pardon l'énergie que
vous avez et en tout cas on vous
souhaite une grande réussite dans
l'éducation nationale parce que ça
touche grand nombre de familles grand
nombre d'enseignants grand nombre
d'enfants grand nombre d'élèves et grand
nombre de parents merci minist je vais
vous laisser répondre aux questions du
rapporteur qui a déjà abordé un nombre
de de sujets dans on va
dire merci monsieur le Président et
merci au rapporteur je vais revenir sur
les différentes questions vous avez
commencé par la formation continue moi
je le redis j'assume ce choix de
positionner la formation continue en
dehors des heures de cours pour limiter
au maximum les heures de cours qui sont
perdu pour nos élèves pour autant
j'assume de dire aussi qu'on a besoin de
formation continue évidemment qu'on a
besoin que les enseignants puissent
accéder et recour à la formation
continue c'est pourquoi je pense que
cette décision peut-être une opportunité
pour améliorer le recours à la formation
continue parce que parfois en écoutant
certains débats ou en regardant certains
commentaires j'ai l'impression que
certains estiment que l'organisation de
la formationue aujourd'hui serait
parfaite ou idéale il y a moins d'un
enseignant sur de au collège qui a
recours et à peine plus d'un enseignant
sur 3 au lycée qui a recours souvent
parce que ils le disent il y a de très
bons formateurs il y a de très bonnes
formations mais l'organisation elle-même
de de la formation ne répond pas
totalement à notre attente on veut des
modules plus courts c'est cables en
hybride sur site dans notre
établissement en collectif avec nos
collègues et c'est exactement ça qu'on
va être qu'on va mettre en place et
qu'on est en train de mettre en place
raison pour laquelle la décision que
j'ai prise s'applique de manière
progressive il s'agit pas de dire on
passe du jour au lendemain à plus aucune
formation continue sur le temps de la
classe j'ai dit 30 % en cette rentrée 50
% au 1er janvier prochain 100 % à la
rentrée prochaine ce qui laisse le temps
à nos écoles académiques de formation
continue réseau canopé et autres de
déployer leur offre de la réadapter pour
qu'on puisse avoir un meilleur recours à
la formation continue sur la formation
initiale c'était la dernière question
mais comme c'est sur la formation je je
couple les deux oui il faut une profonde
réforme de la formation initiale des
enseignants c'est à la fois un levier
essentiel pour l'élévation du niveau de
nos élèves mais c'est aussi un levier
essentiel pour le bien-être de nos
enseignant et c'est un levier essentiel
pour l'attractivité du métier
d'enseignant moi je crois pas du tout à
une crise des vocations je crois pas du
tout qu'il y a une crise d'é voocation
il y a un étudiant sur 4 qui déclare
être intéressé par l'enseignement même
12 % sur un gros volume qui disent
envisager très sérieusement de devenir
enseignant et par ailleurs on a tous
autour de nous des exemples de personnes
qui à 30 40 ou 50 ans après une première
carrière parfois dans le privé ou dans
le public se disent j'ai envie de donner
du sens à mon travail et j'envisage de
devenir enseignant je pense au contraire
qu' a plus de vocation aujourd'hui qu'on
en a connu c'est pas une crise de
vocation c'est une crise d'attractivité
qu'on n'est pas les seuls à connaître
j'étais à hourg hier avec le président
de la République l'Allemagne anticipe
peut-être jusqu'à 25 une pénurie de
25000 enseignants dans les années qui
viennent ils ont un problème
démographique qu'on n' pas qu'on a moins
mais ils sont font face à cette
difficulté au Canada il manque 5000
enseignants et aux États-Unis vous avez
des États qui réduisent la taille des
programmes dans certains états par
manque d'enseignants donc c'est une
crise d'attractivité qui est mondiale
parce que je pense que mondialement il y
a aussi une perte du respect de
l'autorité de l'enseignant de cette
figure et en fait une perte du respect
de l'autorité des savoirs dans la
société la première expression de
l'autorité du savoir c'est l'enseignant
si on ne respecte plus les savoirs on ne
respecte plus
l'enseignant la relation entre un
enseignant et ses élèves ça n'est pas
une relation d'égal à égal il y a celui
qui sait et il y a celui qui apprend et
la relation entre un enseignant et les
familles n'est pas non plus une relation
d'égal à égal et je pense que c'est
toujours important de le rappeler et de
le redire en tout cas nous politiques on
a cette possibilité par ce discours
quand même de rappeler des choses qui
nous semblent à nous évidentes mais qui
malheureusement ne le sont plus
totalement pour tout le monde c'est ce
que disent eux-mêmes les enseignants
ensuite sur l'attractivité il y a la
question de la formation
initiale aujourd'hui vous avez des
enseignants qui sont formés au niveau
master avec un concours à bac+ 5 et
pourtant vous avez un enseignant sur 5
seulement qui se dit suffisamment formé
à la gestion de sa classe pourtant il y
a des difficultés on le sait parfois et
pourtant on a une année de m2 qui par le
positionnement du concours en bac + 5
est devenu beaucoup trop chargé ça
réduit le vivier les les étudiants m2 il
cumulent l'alternance les cours la
rédaction du mémoire il y en a beaucoup
qui démissionnent qui ne sont pas
titularisés donc on doit revoir la
formation des enseignants et notre
ambition je pense que ça rejoint la
philosophie ce que vous avez présenté
dans dans votre texte c'est de créer les
écoles normales du 21e siècle avec une
possibilité on a lancé une concertation
avec les organisations syndicales par
ailleurs je discute aussi avec ma
collègue Sylvie rotaillot évidemment
immédiatement concerné puisqu'elle est
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
avec une ilité d'avoir un concours
positionné avant le bac + 5 compris des
bac+ 3 et ensuite une entrée progressive
dans le métier qui permet de garder le
niveau master une partie des
recrutements qui pourra être fait par
prérecrutement dès le niveau bac et
ensuite avec une une formation
extrêmement dense notamment sur les
fondamentaux et sur un certain nombre de
valeurs essentielles bref beaucoup de
possibilités et on en discute en ce
moment avec les organisations syndicales
euh 3è sujet que vous avez abordé et
j'accélère la médecine scolaire oui on a
besoin de médecine scolaire et notamment
sur la question du harcèlement parce
qu'on sait il y a des élèves qui ont du
mal à parler à leur enseignants qui ont
du mal à parler au chefs d'établissement
qui ont du mal à parler à leur famille
et parfois les personnels sanitaires ou
sociaux c'est des voiesou des oreilles à
qui les élèves se sentent de parler et
oui on a une vraie difficulté et là
aussi c'est une difficulté
d'attractivité puisque vous l'avez dit
les postes sont là mais ils ne sont pas
pourvu sur les médecins on sait on a un
problème global de nombre de médecins
dans notre pays et il ne sera vraiment
résolu que dans quelques années quand
les mesures qu'on a assumé au début du
précédent quinena sur le numerus closus
commenceront à produire leurs effets
avec les étudiants concernés qui
arriveront sur le terrain et d'ici là je
pense qu'on doit inventer aussi de
nouvelles manières de travailler faire
coopérer davantage nos établissements
scolaires avec la médecine de ville avec
les établissements de santé et y compris
pour les infirmières scolaires moi je
pense que ça peut aussi être un levier
d'attractivité pour une infirmière
scolaire que de se dire je peux occuper
un emploi public dans dans un
établissement et en même temps avoir une
activité en libérale à côté si je le
souhaite parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas
possible euh donc on est en train de
travailler à ces solutions il y a
beaucoup d'efforts qui ont été fait sur
la rémunération des personnels de santé
à l'école ces dernières années avec un
réhaussement des gris indiciaires avec
la prime pour les REP REP plus qui
leurit maintenant versé depuis janvier
dernier il y a peut-être encore des
efforts à faire on va regarder mais en
tout cas il me semble que c'est pas
uniquement la question financière qui
nous permettra de répondre à cet enjeu
enfin et dernier point sur la question
du stage pour les élèves de Seconde
d'abord il est très important et moi j'y
tiens beaucoup les pays qui réussissent
mieux que nous sur l'orientation si on
prend l'exemple de l'Allemagne de la
Suède des Pays-Bas c'est des pays où il
y a 3 qu semaines de stage nous là on
dit juste on rajoute 2 semaines en
seconde en plus de la semaine en
3e alors oui c'est un défi parce qu'ils
réaliseront tous leur stage au même
moment c'est pour ça qu'on va devoir se
mobiliser j'ai vu la présidente Carole
Delga des régions de France François
bonau Rena musolier les présidents de
région sont très engagés sur ce sujet-là
ils l'ont dit il y aura une vraie
mobilisation de leur part du tissu
économique les présidents de région
eux-mêmes demandaient la mise en place
d'un stage en seconde donc ils ont été
exaucés et évidemment ils se
mobiliseront j'ai eu les présidents de
fédération du patronat aussi qui se
mobiliseront c'est dans leur intérêt que
de faire découvrir aussi leurs métiers
leurs entreprises à nos élèves on
mobilisera les administrations pour leur
proposer des stages s'agissant de votre
question sur le l'articulation avec le
SNU évidemment des élèves qui
réaliseraient le SNU à ce moment-là
seront dispensés de réaliser un stage
mais on les leur proposera de réaliser
un stage à un autre moment et on les
accompagnera pour ça donc il y aura pas
de concurrence entre les
dispositifs alors nous allons prendre
maintenant la première série de
questions vous êtes très nombreux à
vouloir poser une question ce qui est
très bien par contre je vais vous
demander d'être très incisif et d'aller
directement à la question pour que
chacun puisse s'exprimer on va prendre
un représentant par groupe groupe je
vous donne dans l'ordre de prise de
parole comme ça vous pouvez vous
préparer Marie-Pierre Monier Lord Arcos
George laelc Max Brisson Sonia de la
provoté Monique de Marcou Bernard fialer
Samantha casebonne et emmeric
Durox merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
alors vous venez monsieur de Monsieur le
Ministre de nous refaire les annonces
qui ont marqué la rentrée scolaire un
empilement d'annonce j'ai envie de dire
que l'on a du mal à interpréter
autrement que une tentative peut-être de
diversion dans un contexte où la
première promesse qui devrait être celle
de l'école promesse d'ailleurs martelé
depuis plusieurs mois par l'exécutif
c'est de garantir la présence d'un
enseignant devant chaque élève et la
promesse n'a pas été
tenue face à la fragilisation sans
précédent de notre école laïque publique
et républicaine il est plus que jamais
nécessaire de restaurer la confiance
vous avez parlé d'humain mais il faut
restaurer la confiance et le dialogue
avec tous les membres de la communauté
éducative alors que au contraire vous
faites le choix d'une démarche très
verticale sous couvert vous en avez
reparlé de groupes de travail à qui sont
alloué si j'ai bien compris 8 semaines
seulement 8 semaines pour relever le
défi de l'amélioration du niveau des
élèves vous parlez de concertation
auprès de l'ensemble des enseignants
mais les lignes directrices sont connues
d'avance dans notre rapport bilan des
mesures éducative du quinquena publié en
février 2022 et mené avec mes collègues
Max Brisson et Nick billon nous
pointions les dérivves d'une politique
publique menée dans la précipitation et
à la mise en œuvre mal accompagné j'ai
bien peur que ce nouveau quinquena ne
tire pas la leçon des erreurs commises
précédemment mes questions mont porter
d'abord à nouveau sur la pénurie
d'enseignant et je parle d'une enquête
qui a été faite par le
nspden UNSA qui poait le manque de dans
de plus d'un enseignant dans 58 % des
collèges et des lycées à la rentrée et
je vous le dit à ce jour j'ai encore des
mails de différents établissements où
ils me disent qu'il manque d'enseignant
quelles sont les solutions prévues pour
garantir une présence d'un enseignant
qualifié devant les élèves et j'insiste
sur qualifier parce que c'est un
préalable indispensable pour garantir
l'éducation de nos enfants dans de
bonnes conditions
dans un collège de Gironde c'est le
proviseur qui a publié des petites
annonces et envoyé une lettre aux
parents d'élèves pour qu'on lui
communique des CV c'est ma collègue
Laurence Sibé qui m'en a fait
part comment faire face au déficit de
remplacement tout au long de l'année à
venir dans un contexte où comme vous
l'expliquiez vous-même dans une récente
interview au Monde les remplaçants sont
déjà positionnés sur des postes vacants
dès la
rentrée signature de contrat alors là
des graves dysfonctionnement en matière
de signature de contrat et de
rémunération des personnels non
enseignants AED aesh assistant ou
assistant social ou sociaux des
assistants administratifs qui n'ont à
7ette heure toujours pas de contrat et
pas de rémunération depuis début
septembre en Drome la situation est
tellement dramatique que la commission
départementale d'Action Sociale a dû
hier attribuer des aides d'urgence à
plusieurs personnels à cause de cela
alors il y aurait plusieurs facteurs le
premier c'est peut-être le manque de
personnel administratif au rectorat
c'est aussi un nouveau logiciel qui
peut-être dysfonctionnerait ou serait
pas adapté mais il y a quand même
peut-être aussi
l'impréparation de la mise en place la
cdisation des aesh et des
AED est-ce que vous pouvez nous faire un
état des lieux à ce sujet et nous
indiquer comment vous prévoyez de
régulariser au plus vite la situation de
tous ces personnels qui ne peuvent pas
rester sans contrat ni salaire presque
un mois et demi après la
rentrée il y a aussi un problème avec
les assistants sociaux les contrat de
contractuel un CDD non signé conduisant
à des professionnels à nouveau qui sont
en train de travailler sans salaire hors
cadre légal pour le haine et il y a
aussi un non déploiement des moyens
nécessaires pour couvrir l'ensemble des
besoins et pourtant tout à l'heure vous
avez insisté sur tout le travail à faire
contre le harcèlement scolaire et ce
sont des personnels qui sont justement
là pour la lutte contre le harcèlement
scolaire pouvez-vous m'indiquer comment
vous allez régulariser leur situation et
vous assurer que les postes doivent être
créé alors le PACT enseignant dernière
question dernière question mais
justement je reviens à la valoris
revalorisation des
salaires vous avez en effet beaucoup
communiqué en disant que chaque
enseignant percevrait chaque mois entre
125 et 250 € net en plus mais c'est pas
vrai puisque la revisation valorisation
du point d'indice de la fonction
publique et d'autres avantages ainsi que
la prime exceptionnelle de pouvoir
d'achat de rentrée sont intégrés dans ce
calcul la hausse de 10
% pour tous les enseignants n'a pas été
honoré et donc ce Pact les remontées
qu'on a pareil du syndicat
SNPD et
UNSA disent que il n'aurait pas été
signé dans 30 % des collèges et des
lycées à la rentrée alors nous nous
avons une position très claire nous
sommes contre la logique du pacte
enseignant celle de fait de pouvoir
gagner plus si on doit travailler plus
donc comment et qu'il a il y a de
grandes disparités aussi au niveau des
territoires donc comment allez-vous
désormais assurer l'accès de ces
dispositifs d'accompagnement de
l'ensemble des élèves sur le territoire
et je vous je vous alerte sur deux
points sur ce pacte il y a des
enseignants qui sont amenés à remplacer
des collègues absents pendant leurs
heures de service je connais le CAN un
documentaliste donc il est payé pour des
heures de travail effectu effectué
simultanément et des enseignants des
enseignantes effectuent des
remplacements dans des matières qui ne
sont pas les leurs trouvez-vous ces
situations normales et sont-elles
répandues sur le territoire merci vous
êtes une vingtaine à vouloir s'exprimer
donc si chacun prend 5 minutes on en a
pour plus d'une heure donc s'il vous
plaît soyez vraiment concis Lord Arcos
qui va montrer l'exemple de la concision
ou voilà j'ai le poids oui monsieur le
Président mais je vais je suis content
d'avoir le ministre en face de moi parce
que je vais quand même aussi donner un
un témoignage un peu poignant une
question d'abord très simple très claire
l'année dernière à la même époque j'ai
interrogé votre prédécesseur concernant
les maths dans le Tron commun euh au
baccalauréat parce que la réforme avait
fait en sorte qu'il n'y avait plus de
math euh dans le Tron commun euh ça a
été rétabli à moitié puisque ça n'est
qu'en première et en terminale ça n'est
toujours pas le cas et que du coup euh
ceux qui veulent poursuivre les
mathématiques en terminal euh se
retrouvent en fait dans des classes avec
des matsp et des gens qui sont beaucoup
plus évolués en terme de mathématique et
vraiment je vous assure pour être sur je
le dis devant aussi mon collègue David
Ross sur le plateau de sa clé ça fait
donc deux promotions que nous n'avons
plus assez de candidats pour les écoles
d'ingénieurs aujourd'hui on va manquer
d'éco de d'ingénieur moi je me battais
pour les femmes dans dans les milieux
scientifiques mais là c'est garçons et
filles et donc là c'est vraiment un
sujet quelque chose de beaucoup plus
grave parce que j'étais très touché par
ce que vous avez dit en disant faut que
chaque enfant soit heureux dans dans sa
classe deux exemples premier je sais que
vous pouvez pas changer la face du monde
en en un claquement de doigt qui manque
beaucoup de CSH euh mais il manque aussi
beaucoup de place en imame et je vous le
dis parce que il faut aussi vous en
parliz à votre collègue moi j'ai à La
Ville du Bois un seul exemple deux
enfants les parents savent très bien
qu'il devraient aller en imee et euh ils
ont pas de place il y a pas deesh et ben
ils sont à l'école de La Ville du Bois
on les appelle les enfants du couloir
depuis le début de l'année ils serent
dans les couloirs parce qu'ils ne
tiennent pas en en place et
qu'aujourd'hui et ben ils sont dans les
couloirs à déambuler euh devant leurs
petits camarades et je pense que ça
c'est absolument intenable deuxième
témoignage qui me tient particulièrement
à cœur cé Lian et evve sont dans un
lycée à
d'ourdan euh en première STMG et depuis
15 jours ils subissent un harcèlement
scolaire absolument épouvantable ils se
réfugi au dans le CDI pour à l'heure de
la récréation ou du déjeuner pour ne pas
subir de d'un
insulte le le proviseur a refusé de
recevoir et les parents j'auris demandé
de d'appeler le
3618 on a eu une empathie formidable
c'est-à-dire un mail avec les médiateurs
de directorat de Versailles voilà leur
numéro de téléphone et si ça va pas
appeler le ministre joigz le ministre
j'en ai parlé à Charlotte cobel parce
que c'est aussi son problème mais j'en
ai parlé à la daen la daen a dû sûrement
remonter les BR hôtel du proviseur qui
n'a rien trouvé de mieux que d'exposer
ses deux gamins devant la classe parce
qu'en fait c'est pas un harcèlement de
deux deux élèves contre deux élèves
c'est un harcèlement de deux élèves
contre l'ensemble de la classe parce
qu'ils veulent travailler et la seule
chose qu'on leur a dit c'est euh vous
avez une bonne éducation vous venez
d'ailleurs du privé eux vous comprenez
les pauvres ils n'ont pas de code donc
il y a du racisme anti blanc et du
racisme entre guillemets intellectuel en
fait on les traite d'un tellello et ils
veulent pouvoir travailler donc ces
enfants sont aujourd'hui chez eux parce
que ils ont été arrêtés ils vont suiv
une psychothérapie et il demandent
qu'une seule chose c'est changer
d'établissement pour cette fois-ci je
suis d'accord avec vous c'est mieux que
ça soit le harcellerur qui quitte la la
classe mais dans ce cas-là je vous en
conjure essayer de m'aider pour queil
puisse changer d'établissement George
laelec merci monsieur le président
monsieur le
ministre permettez-moi de me présenter
je suis sénateur des codes d'armur et
pardonnez-moi aussi de le dire ici je
suis le fils d'un ouvrier agricole et
d'une ménagère sans
profession habitant à 4 km
du du bourg d'une commune de 570
habitants je dois donc à l'école de la
République d'avoir fait de moi ce que
modestement je suis mes premiers mots
sont donc des mots de reconnaissance
pour la grande institution dont
présidezvous présider la destinée et
c'est donc avec respect et solennité que
je m'adresse à vous monsieur le ministre
alors s'il est vrai que l'école ne peut
pas tout il n'est pas moins vrai que
l'école peut beaucoup et notre société
en attend beaucoup je voudrais
commencer par vous donner acte d'un
certain nombre d'annonces que vous nous
avez faite dans votre propos liminaire
et un certain nombre d'infléchissement
que vous avez apporté je pense par
exemple au mathématiques qu'on
réhabilite un peu
donact mais il y a deux points
particulierers qui ont retenu mon
attention le premier point c'est celui
de la dite carte
scolaire carte scolaire à laquelle nous
avons été confronté dans bon nombre de
nos territoires et en particulier dans
nos territoires
ruraux parce que vous le savez nos
collectivités s'engag
beaucoup notamment en créant ces RPI ces
regroupements pédagogiques
intercommunaux d'ailleurs qui constitue
peut-être un bout de répon à la crise de
la démographie dont vous parliez dans
vos propos liminires donc autrement dit
on vise un objectif de qualité on se
rassemble on mobilise bien au-delà
d'ailleurs de la communauté éducative
les familles les collectivités et cetera
et s'agissant de ces fameuses cartes
scolaires je me demande si préalablement
à toute
restructuration s'il ne serait pas mieux
d'engager en
amont une démarche visant la recherche
de la qualité éducative du à tout le
monde c'est-à-dire que plutôt que d'être
dans une logique d'application des
quotients mathématiques la règle de
3 consistante à vouloir mettre en
adéquation je dirais les effectifs et
les effectifs scolaires et le nombre
d'enseignants si en amont nous engagions
une démarche visant une offre éducative
de qualité ce serait une bonne manière à
mes yeux meilleure manière d'aborder la
qualité éducative dans le monde dans le
monde rural notamment en second lieu
mais ça a été abordé à l'instant comme
vous je considère que nous sommes
confrontés à une crise de l'attractivité
des métiers de l'enseignement par
conséquent nous sommes preneurs de
toutes les précisions que vous pourriez
apporter et il me semble que la
concertation avec les organisations
syndicales est l'élément quand même le
plus déterminé
pour obtenir le consensus que vous
recherchez merci de votre
attention monsieur Président je vous
promets de pas être plus long que la
représentante la porte-parole du groupe
socialiste monsieur le ministre je serai
dans la bienveillance mais ne vous y
habituez pas
trop je tiens d'abord au nom des sénatri
et sénateurs les républicains vous
féliciter et pour votre nomination de
Gren et pour la rentrée remarquez que
vous avez faite avec un discours qui
tronche avec le nom avec celui de votre
prédécesseur de votre éphémère
prédécesseur jacquérin l'a dit mieux que
moi pour répondre à la demande notre
Président je voudrais vous interroger
sur quatre sujets la
laïcité l'école en milieu rural la
formation des professeurs du premier
degré même si vous avez dit déjà
beaucoup de choses et l'entrée dans le
métier d'enseignant tout d'abord la
laicité pendant des mois face au
chiffres préoccupant voir alarmement du
nombre d'atintte à laïcité nous avons
exhorté sans relâche votre prédécesseur
agir comme l'a dit jacobérin les voix
des chefs d'établissement des
professeurs étaient nombreuses pour
réclamer des instruction précise et un
cadre
clair je salue donc vot votre décision
et ce que vous avez développé et mis en
œuvre avec courage mais je souhaite vous
interroger sur trois sujets rapides ce
matin vous étiez dans une école juive et
je vous en remercie mais la question que
je vous pose ce sont les mesures que
vous allez prendre pour que les enfants
de religion juive ou de culture juive
puissent sans danger fréquenter les
écoles publiques les écoles de la
République et ceci dans tous les
quartiers je pense que c'est un enjeu
majeur de laïcité la deuxème question
que je vous poser sur la cité
elle att tra à la neutralité religieuse
et politique des accompagnateurs lors
des sorties scolaire une sortie scolaire
est en effet un temps qui rentre dans
celui de l'enseignement une forme
d'école hors les murs une classe hors
les murs il semble donc
comme tous les collaborateurs
occasionnels du service public cette
neutralité soit appliquée quelle est
votre position sur le sujet vous qui
avez manifesté déjà des positions sans
ambigué sur la laicité mon trè point
portera sur le Conseil des Sages de la
laïcité il a été bousculé par votre
prédécesseur sa saisie n'est désormais
possible que par le ministre il ne peut
plus sutoaisir
l'élargissement de son périmètre à la
lutte contre le racisme et antisémitisme
et toutes les formes de haine et de
discrimination à l'égalité femme-homme
et la promotion du principe de
fraternité à l'école a dilué le rôle
précieux que lui avait conféré
Jean-Michel Blanquer prévoyez-vous de
revenir sur ces évolutions du conseil
des sages de la
laïcité le deuxème sujet porte sur
l'école rurale
je vais rejoindre ce qu'a dit notre
collègue du groupe
CRCE je voudrais vous dire Monsieur le
Ministre que l'amélioration des
relations entre l'éducation nationale et
les maires ruraux passe par la
rénovation de du partenariat entre les
maires et l'école de la République c'est
un sujet
prioritaire je pense qu'une qu'un des
thèmes que vous devez porter c'est
établir une carte
scolaire
pluriannuel qui s'inscrivent dans le
temps long on demande au maire de ce
pays de plus en plus de s'inscrire dans
des documents d'urbanisme qui leur
conduisent à voir loin et pendant ce
temps le daen ou ou l' vient à l'école
avec sa règle à calculer selon des
procédure digne de la 3e république et
des règles de droit que dont je n'ai pas
toujours compris la totalité les entrées
mais je n'ai jamais été très bon en
mathématiqu alors quand allez-vous
penser ce système
surannée pour être en phase avec les
exigences de l'État en matière
d'urbanisme et surtout pour avoir une
approche particulière des territoires
éducatifs ruraux qui sont eux aussi des
territoires à besoin particulier le
trème sujet porte laavance des
professeurs mon collègue grérin vous a
invité à de bonnes lectures
moi ce que je voudrais vous dire c'est
que le choc des savoirs dont vous avez
parlé nous le partageons vous avez déjà
développé un certain nombre de discours
qui vont dans le bon sens vous avez pris
des mesures je pense particul au
baccalauréat qui vont dans le bon sens
mais pour avoir ce choc des savoirs il
est nécessaire de repenser en profondeur
la formation des professeurs du premier
degré et dans le prolongement des débat
que nous avons eu lorsqu a été examiné
au Sénat laprion de loi que j'avais
l'honneur de porter et dans le
prolongement de ce qu'a dit Jacques
rouperin ma question sera très simple à
quel moment et comment et comment et
pour répondre d'ailleurs à ce qu'a dit
le président de la République lorsqu'il
a parlé de la nécessité de former les
professeurs du premier degré dès après
le bac comment vous
allez faire en sorte que les demandes de
l'employeur qui est l'éducation
nationale soit première par rapport aux
injonctions des universités qui n'ont
pas depuis 20 ans montré leur capacité à
former les professeurs du prier degré la
question est là la question est majeure
vous avez parlé d'école normale du 21e
siècle les écoles normales étaient à la
main de l'éducation nationale c'est le
rôle de l'employeur qui est ici en jeu
après tout les magistrats c'est
peut-être pas toujours une réussite sont
formés dans une école à la mer du
ministère de la Culture il me semble
nécessaire qu'au moins les les profess
du ministère de la Justice il me semble
au moins nécessaire que les professeurs
du prer degré répondent aux attentes de
l'État employeur le dernier
point j'ai peutêre été plus long que
marieierre Monier et je vous
présenteéatement mes excuses le 4è le
dernier point le derer monsieur le
ministre comment allez-vous mettre un
terme c'est essentiel pour la
valorisation du métier d'enseignant et
son attractivité comment allez-vous
mettre un terme au bisutage
institutionnel que les jeunes
professeurs quand ils rentrent dans le
métier subissent après tout ils sont
d'abord bisutés par l'institution que
vous avez désormis l'odeur de diruger je
vous remercie voilà voyez monsieur le
ministre que le respect de l'autorité ne
se pose pas que dans les salles de
classe ça fait 2 minutes pour de la
provoté non je suis pas plus ente que
les autres merci j'ai aucune notion du
temps quand j'interviens c'est pour mon
voisin de derrière je dis ça euh non
merci Monsieur min quatre questions je
vais je vous promets je fais plus court
la première porte sur le pas de vague et
sur les violences envers les les les
enseignants un professeur sur deux a été
victime d'une agression se dit avoir été
victime d'une agression on a eu une
audition avec votre prédécesseur il y a
quelques mois euh et et clairement on a
du mal à voir quels sont les moyens la
stratégie qui vont être mis en place il
s'était engagé notamment sur une une
étude un peu géographique et de
caractérisation des agresseurs euh pour
voir comment on pouvait adapter euh
notamment en termes de ressources
humaines et de compétences le
l'accompagnement de l'éducation
nationale et le pas de vague pour tout
vous dire des témoignage que j'en ai y
compris dans mon euh dans mon
département euh existe encore euh et on
demande plutôt de se taire que de faire
des vagues euh voilà donc c'est un
témoignage tout à fait récent euh ma
deuxème question porte sur les écoles
hors contr contrat elles sont encore en
augmentation de façon exponentielle euh
avec en 3 ans une multiplication énorme
de de des élèves plus de 11200 élèves
dans dans le primire on est passé de 49
à 6,2 % des élèves dans les écoles
privées euh par qui sont hors contrat on
a donc beaucoup d'enfants qui échappent
un peu au radar de l'éducation nationale
au sens républicain du terme et sans
jeter l'eau probre sur tous les
établissements euh quels ont été les
moyens et quel bilan vous tirez euh à la
fois de cette augmentation de l'école de
la scolarisation contrat et et et et
est-ce que vous avez identifié des
pistes d'amélioration car on imagine
qu'un certain nombre sont nécessaires
euh pour pouvoir prendre en compte ce
sujet on peut pas traiter les questions
par exemple de laïcité mais pas que hein
il y a les pédagogies alternatives et ne
pas s'enquérir de façon ferme de de ce
sujet ma trème question porte sur
l'éducation artistique et culturelle et
donc le fameux 100 % EAC que que vous
avez euh que vous avez évoqué où en
est-on et quel est le bilan réel
puisque'à une époque le AC c'était
vraiment des actions portées par les
établissement portés par les enseignants
avec un réseau d'intervenants et qui
était bien identifié et qui qui faisait
fonctionner un écosystème entre les
collectivités les structures
associatives les les les personnalités
issues du monde culturel et et
l'éducation national et on sait que le
passeculture a amené un filtre
complémentaire et a fait différer et a
fait disparaître pas mal d'actions et
pas mal d'intervenants surtout qui
étaient très très investis dans dans
l'éducation des jeunes et qui et et qui
n'avaient pas démérité et cet écosystème
là le passculture le fragilise très
clairement et donc il y a un retour
quand même à faire sur sur sur cette
notion et notamment si le passculture
est un outil est pas pour autant une
stratégie en matière d'éducation
artistique et culturelle et donc quelle
est votre stratégie en l'espèce et
avez-vous des priorités qui sont
identifié et ma dernière question parle
porte sur l'expérimentation euh et de la
modification du zonage d'éducation
prioritaire une cartographie nouvelle
devit être mise en place des nouvelles
pistes euh des notamment des
propositions de suivi particulier des
éducations des élèves relevant
d'éducation prioritaire qui n'étaient
pourtant pas euh dans des zones de
d'éducation prioritaire en fait toutes
ces sujets qui faisaient qu'un certain
nombre d'élèves qui pouvaient être
qualifiés éducation prioritaire n'étit
pas pris en charge dans les mêmes
conditions que dans dans le zonage
identifié donc où on en est de de ce
sujet je vous
remercie merci merci écoutez monsieur le
ministre bienvenue vous voyez que vous
avez un lot de questions euh moi je vais
être très courte je pense que vous
pourrez pas répondre aujourd'hui mais je
préfère la poser euh la première qui me
venait à l'idée c'était celle sur
l'empathie vous avez fait une des
annonces concernant l'empathie comment
comptez-vous les mettre en œuvre et
comment est-ce que ça sera avec
l'enseignement peut-être
civique moral et civique voilà céit une
question mais cette rentrée ma question
elle portée sur cette rentrée scolaire
avec avec des élèves de 6e qui n'ont pas
plus cours plus cours de technologie
cette heure a été remplacée justement
par une heure de de mathématiqu et de
français comme si la technologie n'était
pas également une matière où on
utilisait le français et les
mathématiques c'était une annonce
brutale qui a été faite par votre
prédécesseur sans aucune concertation
cette suppression de la technologie
traduit à mon sens une mconnaissance
totale des enjeux éducatifs du 21e
siècle cette matière est directement
liée aux enjeux numériques et
climatiques cette matière permet
également de susciter
d'évocation pour le numérique pour les
sciences de l'ingénieur et pour la voie
professionnelle auriez-vous l'intention
de revenir sur cette décision
comptez-vous renforcer alors sur des
autres niveaux après la 6e cet
enseignement de la technologie et
comment mais je j'accepterai que vous me
répondiez plus
tard Berard
fialer merci monsieur le Président donc
monsieur le le ministre tout d'abord moi
aussi je voudrais vous vous féliciter
d'abord pour vos premières prise de de
parole et la réhabilitation de et même
que vous avez incarné l'autorité et oser
l'affirmer je crois que c'est quelque
chose d'important c'est ce qui et qui
passe par le respect des savoirs et et
des enseignants moi je autant il faut
une autorité quelque chose de de
qui ne doit pas imposer une rigidité si
vous voulez dans pour l'éducation
nationale et la coopération par exemple
avec entre l'éducation nationale les
communes les départements les régions
est extrêmement importante on a vu sur
pour les départements sur la médecine
scolaire et tous les problèmes sociaux
que portent déjà les département avec la
PMI et leurs services médicaux-sociaux
de temps en temps il y a redondance et
et même parfois il y a une impossibilité
d'être très efficace puisque les les
assistants social sociaux des des
établissements scolaires savent pas
forcément ce qui se passe exactement
dans les familles ce que peuvent avoir
au contraire les services sociaux des
départements et puis lorsqu'on a suivi
des
enfants depuis presque la naissance dans
la PMI on a repéré aussi les handicaps
et le fait que ça puisse être suivi
apporte un petit peu
d'efficacité pour ce qui est de la ville
il peut pas y avoir des règles si vous
voulez qui sont appliqués par les
éducateurs de rue ouou dans le
périscolaire que M en place les communes
et d'autres à l'intérieur des
établissements et le fait qu'il puisse y
avoir vraiment une une prolongation sera
importante et puis vous avez parlé
l'action des régions pour les stages
pour l'orientation qui est aussi quelque
chose d'important donc ça c'est vraiment
quelque quelque chose auquel je je tiens
un peu dans dans l'esprit des cités
éducatives qui ont fait leur preuve
quand même sur certains territoires moi
j'aurais deux questions la première
c'est vous avez parlé de
l'évolution de l'enseignement moral et
civique il y a une mission d'information
sur la culture citoyenne d'ailleurs mené
par Stéphane piernoir et et Cabanel qui
va déboucher sur une PPL je rapporterai
tendant à renforcer la culture citoyenne
et qui revient quand même sur cet
enseignement moral et civique qui
devrait être un petit peu délesté de de
de
certains enseignements qui qui relèvent
du code de l'éducation je parle des
gestes du premier secours les infos
données sur le don d'organ sur la
sensibilisation des conduites addictives
et qu'on puisse consacrer un petit peu
plus de temps avec peut-être aussi des
programmes
dont la rédaction soit moins confuse et
qui soit pas remis en question chaque
année pour que les enseignants se les
approprient puisqu'ils ont changé une
fois par an ces dernières années et puis
toute dernière question qui me vient de
du président de de l'Association des
mères ruraux de mon de mon
département ce sont les règles de
participation des communes aux écoles
privées de leur
commune vous savez quel le calcul est
fait par la division
des
coûts par élève de l'école publique qui
doivent être versé l'école privée ils
sont confrontés actuellement à une
augmentation des coûts de des matières
énergétiques qui sont importantes
lorsque le nombre d'élèves diminue quand
vous avez une classe de 25 élèves et
qu'il y en a plus que 20 dans certaines
écoles rurales savoir que les coût sont
à peu près fixes il y a pas de division
mais ça renchérit la
participation finalement à l'école
privée et du coup si la commune veut
faire
l'effort d'investir davantage pour la
rendre attractive et compétitive et bien
ils ont une double peine en étant obligé
encore de payer davantage que le privé
donc est-ce qu'on pourrait pas revoir un
petit peu le mode de calcul sur les
places disponibles dans une école plutôt
que les places effectivement
occupé
samanabon merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre d'AB vous féliciter
pour vos prises de positions
courageusees en cette rentrée et bien
sûr votre nomination j'aborderai trois
points qui concernent les plus de 400000
élèves des écoles françaises à
l'étranger mais avant je tenais à
envoyer nos pensées à nos communautés
scolaires des lycées français de de Tel
Aviv et de
Jérusalem je tiens aussi à vous
remercier pour votre engagement sans
équivoque contre le harcèlement scolaire
vous avez envoyé des messages de soutien
fort aux victim et à leurs familles qui
reprennent espoir de voir la peur
changer de camp et il me demande de vous
le faire savoir si nous sommes encore au
début d'un changement d'ampleur je
souhaitais évoquer avec vous la mise en
place de ce dispositif prévu sur le
territoire
national et sa transposition au aux
élèves des lycées français de l'étranger
il existe cert des dispositifs de lutte
contre le harcèlement dans un certain
nombre de nos établissements français à
l'étranger mais il reste encore beaucoup
à faire dans la mise en œuvre et dans la
formation de tous les personnels des
élèves et des
parents nous devons en effet aller
encore plus loin pour accompagner ses
élèves et ses familles victimes qui
doivent parfois sortir du système
français sans autre alternative que de
rentrer en France ou de s'inscrire dans
un système scolaire étranger donc ma
première question et n'aurions-nous pas
intérêt à coordonner nos forces avec
l'Inspection générale du ministère de
l'Éducation nationale la médiatrice de
l'éducation nationale la EFE l'agence
d'enseignement français à l'étranger et
les opérateurs d'enseignement français
sous la tutelle du ministère des
Affaires étrangères pour transposer ces
dispositifs nationaux au réseau français
de l'étranger deème point vous Rappelz
également que nous pouvons être fiers
que depuis 2020 des familles françaises
dont les enfants sont en situation de
handicap et scolarisé au sein du réseau
de l'enseignement français à l'étranger
bénéficie désormais d'une bourse pour le
financement des aesh ainsi plus de 283
élèves à cette rentrée sont accompagnés
financièrement et ce depuis 3 ans
maintenant si nous sommes heureux que ce
dispositif se développe au sein du
réseau je souhaite attirer votre
attention sur le fait qu'il faut dès à
présent prévoir de nouveaux moyens en
formation des personnels qui sont
souvent des personnels de droit local et
qui peuvent parfois manquer de
connaissance du système pédagogique
français peut-être que ce point monsieur
le ministre mériterait dès à présent un
diagnostic de l'inspection générale afin
de pouvoir accompagner au mieux ce
dispositif qui monte fortement en
puissance au sein de notre réseau et
enfin dernier point le décrit CR de 2019
de l'enseignement français toujours à
l'étranger prévoit un détachement de
deux fois 3 ans des personnels de
l'Éducation nationale en contrepartie de
leur retour en France il avait été pris
l'engagement de les accompagner au
retour de construire un parcours
professionnel avec eux pour valoriser
leur acquis d'expérience afin qu'ils
puissent bénéficier d'une valorisation
de leur parcours à l'étranger
malheureusement aujourd'hui encore on ne
reconnaît pas suffisamment ces
personnels qui maîtrisent des langues
des bivalences parfois des parcours de
formateurs les consultations d'avril
dernier sur l'enseignement français à
l'étranger mené par le ministère des
Affaires étrangères et votre ministère
et particulièrement l'atelier encadré
par l'Inspection générale et les
ressources humaines ont commencé à
recenser des propositions fait par les
personnels et les équipes de direction
et bien sûr votre administration
pourriez-vous nous dire si un groupe de
travail va être ouvert au niveau des
ressources humaines du ministère de
l'Éducation nationale car les détachés
relevant du décret de 2019 devront en
fin d'année scolaire 2024 préparer leur
retour nous ne pouvons pas les laisser
donc sans une reconnaissance de leur
parcours et de leur engagement d'autant
que vous le savez nous accueillons
aujourd'hui près de 400000 élèves dans
580 établissement et ce donc correspond
à plus de 30000 élèves depuis le
lancement de cap 2030 voulu par le le
président de la République et qu'ils ont
contribué eux aussi à l'effort pour
atteindre cet
objectif
et enfin voilà Emeric
durx monsieur le monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Président merci de me donner
la parole euh beaucoup de choses ont été
dites je vais essayer d'être quelque peu
concis je vais parler du problème
d'attractivité de notre métier je dis
notre métier parce qu'il y a encore de
semaines j'étaéis professeur
d'histoiregéographie juste avant mon mon
élection un sujet que que je connais
bien euh on pourrait résumer la
situation en disant qu'aujourd'hui de
moins en moins d'étudiants contrairement
à ce que vous avez dit veulent devenir
professeurs et de plus en plus de
professeurs quittent le métier je
voudrais citer ce chiffre 75 % des
ruptures conventionnelles dans la
fonction publique concernne des agents
de votre ministère alors que ces
derniers ne représentent que 64 % des
agents de la fonction publique
eu il y a un problème de rémunération je
vais ça a été dit je vais je vais être
assez assez concis je je vais je vais
prendre mon cas personnel j'étais
échelon 7 jusqu'à donc de semaines et en
tant qu'échelon 7 j'allais gagner en
effet environ 145 € en plus par mois
mais à l'échelon 8 mes collègues
n'allaient gagner que 80 € en plus euh
pour mon cas personnel toujours je suis
très transparent avec vous j'allais
gagner environ j'allais passer de 2200 €
par mois à 2350 € ce qui au bout de 10
ans d'expérience surtout en région
parenzienne vous en conviendrez est
assez peu et ceci sans 13e mois sans
tickets resto sans médecine du travail
sans comité d'entreprise je n'ai jamais
compris pourquoi alors que nous pesons
un million de fonctionnaires on éétait
pas capable de faire en sorte que les
professeurs qui ont certes beaucoup de
vacances et qui sont finalement
incapables d'en prendre parce qu'ils ont
pas les moyens de partir plus d'une
semaine n'avaient pas des des des des
prix négoier alors que nous représentous
représentons une force de frappe très
conséquente hein donc on a 4 mois de
vacances mais on peut partir qu'une
semaine
h donc je je pense que de ce point de
vue-là il y a des choses à travailler
pour renforcer l'attractivité et donc ma
questionà au-delà des des
revalorisations qui en plus ne rattrape
pas le pouvoir d'achat perdu en 30 ans
qui ont été largement renié par
l'inflation et qui en plus pour la
plupart d'entre elles sont sous forme
d'indemnité qui ne compte pas pour la
retraite et bien je voulais savoir si et
bien vous aviez des pistes pour
améliorer concrètement la situation
matérielle de beaucoup d'enseignants des
800000 enseignants de France je vous
remercie voilà évidemment il y a
plusieurs thèmes qui se recoupent je
vais vous laisser répondre et regrouper
peut-être les les réponses ou merci il y
a plusieurs effectivement interventions
qui ont repris des thème comparable et
donc je vais tâcher d'y répondre de la
manière la plus
exhaustive possible d'abord
peut-être démarrer sur la question de la
rentrée scolaire évidemment on a eu
l'occasion de le dire l'objectif qui a
été fixé c'est que tous les postes soit
pourvu pour la rentrée scolaire en
l'occurrence quand on a fait le dernier
point à la mi-septembre la fin septembre
on était à
99,95 % de postes pourvus ce à quoi vous
faites référence madame la sénatrice ça
n'est pas des postes que nous n'avons
pas été capable de pourvoir ce sont des
postes qui ont été pourvus mais dont les
enseignants qui avaient pourvu ces
postes étaient absents donc quand vous
parlez de chaise vide c'est en réalité
des enseignants que vous visez qui ont
été absents moi je suis pas dans le
fonctionnaire baching ou dans le
enseignant bashing donc je je ne partage
pas les propos que vous avez tenus euh
c'est des enseignants qui qui était
absent mais qui était affecté sur un
poste donc l'objectif c'est précisément
de pouvoir assurer le remplacement quand
il y a des absences et c'est l'un des
enjeux du pacte enseignant alors vous
dites c'est des missions supplémentaires
il y a déjà beaucoup d'enseignants qui
font du remplacement de courte durée
avec des heures supplémentaire en
moyenne 2 heures par semaine donc c'est
c'est c'est c'est déjà une réalité dans
nos établissements simplement là ils
seront mieux rémunérés ça passe de 40 €
à 70 € de l'heure donc c'est du plus
pour ces enseignants qui s'engagent qui
s'engage davantage je veux insister sur
le fait puisque vous avez dit j'insiste
sur le besoin d'enseignant qualifié vous
Avaz insisté plusieurs fois sur
qualifier je pense que c'était peut-être
une référence au contractuel moi je veux
remercier et saluer les enseignants et
contractuel qui sont auprès de nos
élèves c'est 5 % de nos enseignants
finalement notre objectif c'est d'avoir
le plus de titulaires possible mais je
veux rappeler que 90 % d'entre eux
enseignaient déjà l'année dernière ils
ont acquis en cela une expérience mais
mais évidemment notre objectif c'est
qu'il puisse être être titularisé sur la
question des contrats non signés ou
salaires non versés effectivement on a
eu un certain nombre d'alertes notamment
à Mayotte sur des contractuels Mayotte
qui connaît d'ailleurs beaucoup d'autres
et bien d'autres difficultés sur
lesquelles on pourra revenir si vous le
souhaitez mais également dans le
valdoise où il y a un certain nombre de
dossiers notamment d'aesh qui ont dû
être repris à la main euh ce qui a
entraîné effectivement des délais donc
la consigne que j'ai donné à l'ensemble
des rectorats c'est de verser
immédiatement des accomtes euh de
manière on se retrouve pas ou jusqu'à 90
% de manière à ce qu'on se retrouve pas
avec effectivement des personnels qui ne
n'ont pas de rémunération pendant un
certain temps on agit pour régler ces
ces ces situations sur la rémunération
des enseignants je veux vraiment pour le
coup là me permettre de corriger ce que
je ne fais pas souvent mais ce que vous
avez dit contrairement à ce que vous
avez dit dans le calcul qui est fait
pour dire qu'entre septembre 2022 et
septembre 2023 tous les enseignants
gagnent entre 125 et 250 € nets de plus
il n'y a pas la prime exceptionnelle de
pouvoir d'achat dans ce calcul elle n'en
fait pas partie il y a effectivement euh
la revalorisation du point d'indice qui
en fait partie celle qui a eu lieu cet
été qui concerne tout le monde enfin les
syndicats enseignants demandaient aussi
euh cette revalorisation du point
d'indice donc ça me semble normal qu'on
l'intègre euh dedans il faut se rendre
compte quand même du chemin parcouru un
enseignant en début de carrière né au
tiulaire il y a 3 ans il gagnait 1700 €
net par mois on est à 2100 € net par
mois c'est 400 € de plus en 3 ans alors
j'entends hein que évidemment il faut
que ça continue à augmenter entend
parfaitement ses demandes enfin faut
aussi reconnaître et mesurer le chemin
qui a été parcouru dans une
administration qui compte 860000
enseignants donc évidemment dès que vous
prenez une mesure de revalorisation tout
de suite c'est des des sommes
budgétaires très importantes je suis
bien placé pour le savoir j'étais de
l'autre côté de la scène à Bercy quand
ces décisions ont ont été
prises sur ensuite la question sur les
maths on n'est pas du tout au bout de ce
qu'il faut faire pour redresser le
niveau en mathématique dans notre pays
pas du tout mais c'était d'abord très
important temps de rétablir les maths
dans le Tron commun en première comme on
le fait en cette rentrée mais on n'est
pas au bout il faut continuer à agir
dans le premier degré au collège
peut-être au lycée on verra j'attends de
voir les propositions qui me seront
faites par la Mission exigence des
savoirs que j'ai engagé ah oui madame
mon j'ai oublié de vous répondre vous
disiez 8 semaines c'est très court pour
agir en même temps sur cette question de
l'élévation du niveau il y a honnêtement
énormément de rapports d'audit d'avis de
propositions y compris de parlementaires
de sénateur du conseil scientifique de
l'éducation nationale de l'inspection
générale je pense que maintenant il est
peut-être temps de concrétiser tout ça
donc la mission que j'ai installé hier
elle vise à s'appuyer aussi sur cette
somme de rapports et de travaux qui ont
été remis ces dernières années pour
faire des proposition opérationnelle
donc oui on aura la possibilité
d'avancer rapidement et je vais vous le
dire on le doit à nos élèves on le doit
à nos élèves de prendre les mesures
nécessaires pour élever le niveau donc
sur les maths on va continuer j'ai
ouvert un certain nombre de pistes euh
dans mon intervention à la BNF de la
semaine dernière notamment pour élever
le niveau le fait peut-être de
fonctionner au moins sur le français et
les mathématiques par des groupes de
compétences au collège je pense que
c'est une piste intéressante à la fin et
ça c'est des enseignants eux-mêmes qui
me le disent quand vous avez des élèves
qui ont un niveau tellement différent
sur les mathématiques ou sur le français
dans une même classe vous finissez par
tirer tout le monde vers le bas parce
que ceux qui ont le niveau ne peuvent
plus progresser et les autres n'arrivent
pas à progresser
donc moi j'assume de dire que sur le
français et les
mathématiques c'est une piste ça se
regarde c'est pas là une annonce que je
suis en train de faire mais en tout cas
je souhaite que la mission puisse y
travailler expertiser s'il ne serait pas
opportun de penser une organisation sur
le français et les mathématiques par
groupe de compétenence au
collège je pose la question non non non
attention hein je suis pas en train de
dire non je suis pas en train de dire
qu'on revient sur le collège unique je
suis pas en train de dire non
je ne suis pas en train de dire je ne
suis pas en train de dire non non je ne
suis pas en train de dire même que je
suis pour le retour des classes de
niveau moi je suis pour qu'on continue à
avoir un groupe classe avec des élèves
très différents ce que je dis mais vous
savez en fait déjà des 7 rentrées on
commence à le faire puisque pour l'URE
supplémentaire dont tu as parlé Madame
De Marco à la place de l'URE de
technologie en français en mathématique
on fonctionne par groupe de compétences
puisque sur cette heure supplémentaire
de français mathématique de soutien
approfondissement oui c'est sur une
heure ce que je veux dire c'est voilà ça
pas ENF voilà on est toujours dans le
collège unique je dis simplement que la
question se pose si on veut faire
progresser tout le monde de savoir s'il
faut garder des élèves avec un niveau
aussi hétérogène et ce qui par ailleurs
permettrait aussi peut-être pour des
élèves qui en ont le plus besoin d'avoir
des plus petits groupes dans ces
discipline et pour des élèves dont on
voit que ils ont des compétences à un
niveau qui leur permet d'avancer plus
rapidement d'avoir des groupes plus
importants vous AZ un syndicat un
syndicat enseignant le snalk pour ne pas
le citer avait fait une proposition il y
a quelques années de collège modulaire
j'ai demandé à la mission de regarder ce
sujet-là je vois que ça déchaîne les
passions ici au Sénat donc je suis ravi
je me réjouis de revenir en parler avec
vous quand on prendra des
décisions alors laissez finir le
ministre ensuite c'est aussi mon
bisutage j'imagine pour cette première
audition euh sur l'école inclusive sujet
absolument majeur euh oui il y a un
manque de place en IME et j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire à mes collègues
horuror berger et Fadila catabi elles se
sont engagé auprès de moi à ce qu'on
avance sur ce sujet-là
la réalité c'est que sur l'école
inclusive on a fait d'énormes progrès
quantitatifs en terme de nombre d'élèves
accueillis depuis
2017 plus de 100000 élèves de plus qui
sont accueillis parce qu'on a créé 40000
postes d'Es on est en train de
déprécariser ce métier avec plus de 50 %
qui sont en CDI des revalorisations même
s'il faut continuer à agir sur le temps
de travail je le disais tout à l'heure
maintenant il faut qu'on avance vers du
qualitatif et moi j'avoue je suis frappé
par beaucoup d'enseignants professeurs
des écoles notamment que je Ren compte
qui me disent qu'il se sentent parfois
dépassés
et c'est un peu ce que vous avez dit
dans votre intervention donc il y a la
transformation à venir des piales en
passe moi je pense que c'est une bonne
piste parce que ça serait un point
d'entrée unique pour les familles pour
les accompagn y compris dans leur
démarche avec la MDPH aujourd'hui les
pial c'est essentiellement ça ça gère
essentiellement entre guillemets
administrativement les aesh là l'idée
c'est aussi qu'à travers ses passes on
puisse faire intervenir des personnels
du médico-social auprès des enseignants
et des professeurs des écoles autre
sujet il faut qu'on renforce aussi les
heures de
scolarité dans les établissements
médicaux-sociaux parce que la réité
c'est que vous avez aujourd'hui parfois
des
familles pour qui la MDPH prescrit un
une une place un accueil en
établissement médico-social en im ou en
ITEP et la famille elle-même souhaite
que l'enfant puisse aller à l'école
parce qu'il y a plus d'heures de cours
donc il faut qu'on arrive aussi à avoir
davantage de scolarité dans ses
établissements médicausociaux parfois
vous avez des familles pour qui ont
prescrit une place en IME ou en ITEP qui
souhaitent mettre leurs enfants leur
enfants dans un établissement
médico-social mais qui fautent de place
ne le peuvent pas et donc effectivement
il va à l'école qu'on soit clair
l'objectif c'est que l'objectif c'est
que on ait le meilleur accompagnement
possible pour tous les élèves tous les
élèves et tous les enfants de la
République quelle que soit leur
situation leur handicap ont le droit à
être scolarisé dans les meilleures
conditions possibles pour eux parfois ça
passe le plus souvent ça passe par
l'école en milieu ordinaire avec un
accompagnement une adaptation par fois
ça passe par une place en établissement
médico-social dans lequel il doit y
avoir de l'école j'insiste aussi sur la
mission qui a été confiée au président
du département de la Somme monsieur USS
Soulier et à Luce Carasco très engagé
sur les questions de handicap justement
sur le rapprochement entre ime enfin
établissement médicaux sociaux et école
mais je le dis je suis ce sujet là est
important pour moi parce que je ne
voudrais pas que certains cherchent
instrumentaliser ces situations
difficiles sur le terrain pour essayer
de nous faire revenir sur l'école
inclusive
y compris une instrumentalisation
politique j'ai observé peut-être comme
un certain nombre d'entre vous que
l'extrême droite allemande lafd il y a
quelques mois a annoncé qu'elle mettait
désormais au cœur de son projet
politique le rejet de l'école inclusive
et j'ai observé que en France lors de la
dernière élection présidentielle un
candidat a commencé à toucher du doigt
ce sujet-là moi je ne veux pas qu'on
revienne sur ce progrès quand même
qui'est l'accueil des élèves en
situation de handicap à l'école et donc
il faut qu'on soit capable de répondre
aujourd'hui au préocup pass qui sont
exprimés par les familles par les élèves
et par les professeurs des écoles désolé
je suis un peu long mais ça me semble
être un sujet qui le mérite et qui le
justifie sur le harcèlement évidemment
on va regarder le cas que vous évoquez
quand on dit c'est à l'élève harceleur
de changer d'établissement et pas
l'élève harcelé d'abord il faut que ça
arrive en fin de de de course entre
guillemets c'estàdire que avant il faut
tout faire pour régler la situation sans
avoir à en arriver là notamment dans le
premier degré mais enfin c'est important
qu'il puisse y avoir cette sanction si
on règle pas la situation de si
effectivement les élèves eux-mêmes après
qu'on est exploré avec toutes les
propositions souhaitent eux-mêmes
changer il faut qu'ils puissent le faire
mais il faut d'abord que ils a
conscience et qu'on leur donne toutes
les conditions pour qu'ils se disent
qu'ils ont le choix et donc sur ce sujet
on va regarder la situation que vous
évoquez de manière évidemment très
importante sur monsieur la vous avez
parlé donc sur les mathématiques j'ai
répondu sur la qualité éducatif dans le
monde rural et plusieurs sont intervenus
sur sur ce sujet là oui il faut donner
de la visibilité plus annuel pour le
coup on peut beaucoup plus le faire en
milieu rural qu'en milieu urbain euh il
faut donner cette visibilité
pluri-annuelle c'est un engagement qui a
été pris par la première ministre dans
le cadre de France ruralité il y a
maintenant une instance au niveau
départemental avec les services dsdenen
et les élus locaux pour donner cette
visibilité sur 3 ans et donc voilà il
faut maintenant que cette instance se
metent en place qu'elle fonctionne bien
et qu'elle puisse donner cette
visibilité je suivrai de très près sa
mise en œuvre sur la question de
l'attractivité là aussi plusieurs
d'entre vous en ont parl parler donc je
vais répondre en répondant à Monsieur
LEC oui c'est un enjeu absolument majeur
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire comment
est-ce qu'on retrouve l'attractivité la
question des salaires j'ai l'occasion de
dire ce qu'on a engagé ce qu'on a fait
il a la question de la formation
initiale là aussi j'ai répondu il y a la
question du déroulement de la carrière
la progression de carrière on voit dans
un certain nombre d'études et d'ailleurs
dans certain nombre d'échanges avec des
organisations syndicales ou des
enseignants qu'au milieu de la carrière
il y a probablement en terme de
progression à la fois
salarial mais aussi d'opportunités qui
peuvent être offertes quelque chose à
faire il y a un sujet aussi je pense de
capacité pour l'administration éducation
nationale à permettre aux enseignants
d'identifier de valoriser et de
certifier les compétences acquises par
l'enseignement aujourd'hui vous échangez
avec des jeunes vous en trouvez assez
peu qui vous disent qu'il se voi faire
le même métier toute leur vie ils le
disent souvent j'aurais 1 vie dans ma
vie et mais pourquoi est-ce qu'il en
serait différemment pour l'éducation
nationale évidemment si des jeunes
souhaitent devenir enseignants et
souhaitent l'être toute leur vie on sera
les premiers ravis et on fera tout pour
qu'ils aient envie d'y rester mais il
faut pas qu'on renvoie l'idée à ces
jeunes candidats euh que c'est qui ne
pourront pas faire autre chose s'ils en
ont envie à un moment dans leur vie et
d'ailleurs quand vous échangez avec des
employeurs privés ou publics ils vous
disent qu'a priori quelqu'un qui a géré
une classe au hasard de collège pendant
15 ans en terme de résilience de
capacité à s'adapter de compétences qui
ont été acquises évidemment qu'il a
beaucoup de choses à à valoriser s'il
veut faire autre chose donc je pense
qu'il faut aussi qu'on soit capable
d'avoir cette rénovation de l'animation
de carrière de la valorisation des
carrières pour les enseignants qui le
souhaiteraient ça sera aussi un des
éléments de l'attractivité et enfin il y
a un sujet qui est majeur et là j'ai vu
que vous aviez fait des propositions
donc on va regarder on en parle avec les
syndicats qui est celui des affectations
et mutations évidemment que c'est un
frein pour certains et que vous avez
même certains candidats qui se disent
bah je préfère ne pas être titulaire et
passer le concours être contractuel pour
pouvoir rester dans mon académie donc
après donc moi je suis pragmatique
lucide je pense que si un système
parfait qui contentait tout le monde
existait j'ose espérer que certains de
mes prédécesseurs l'auraient trouver ou
identifier mais pas sûr peut-être qu'il
n'avait pas il ne connaissait pas le
Sénat et donc on va regarder votre
proposition et on va on y travaille avec
les organisations syndicales si on
arrive à trouver par exemple un système
qui permet de dire à un enseignant si
vous acceptez telle mutation telle
affectation on vous donne la garantie
qu'au bout de 3 ans ou 5 ans vous aurez
un retour dans votre académie d'origine
avec la possibilité de choisir peut-être
que ça permettra de faciliter les choses
donc il faut que ce système soit
faisable qu'il existe ça fait partie à
la fois de ce qu'on discute dans la
concertation avec les organisations
syndicales sur l'attractivité et j'ai
aussi missionné le Conseil scientifique
de l'éducation nationale pour qu'il me
fasse une proposition sur le sujet
évidemment tous ces travaux s'appuieront
aussi sur les propositions que vous
avezit fait euh mais comme quoi encore
une fois madame Monier euh il y a il y a
plein de rapports qui existent de
proposition donc maintenant on peut
avancer euh excusez-moi monsieur le
ministre je crois que c'est dans la PPL
de Max Brisson doncoui et dans et dans
le rapport sur le métier d'enseignant
qu'on avait livré avec Françoise labord
il y a déjà quelques quelques années de
3 ans sur le contrat me semble être une
bonne réponse donc on regardera euh
évidemment à cette cette proposition euh
monsieur euh Brisson euh sur la
laïcité vous avez l'avez dit j'étais ce
matin avec Gérald
dararmanin dans une école juive de de
sarcell pour réaffirmer évidemment la
promesse de la République qui est la
protection de tous ces enfants il soit
scolarisé à l'école publique ou dans une
école privée école
confessionnelle ce que nous avons eu
l'occasion de rappeler c'est qu'il y a
un déploiement très important de force
de sécurité je veux leur rendre hommage
pour sécuriser d'une manière générale
les établissements de confession juives
mais en particulier les écoles avec une
présence de policiers statique devant
les établissements ça c'est absolument
majeur ça a été redit ce matin par le
Ministre de l'Intérieur et je remercie
le ministre de l'Intérieur et les
services de son ministère pour la
sécurité qui a ainsi apporté à ses
élèves évidemment je je comprends la la
préoccupation des familles et leurs
inquiétudes et c'est notre
responsabilité qu'être au rendez-vous
avec les moyens nécessaires ils sont là
ensuite vous avez abordé un autre sujet
absolument majeur qui est la sécurité
des élèves de confession juif dans
l'école publique qui est un sujet qui ne
date pas de ce conflit on le sait il a
des
agressions de
l'antisémitisme qui se déploie depuis
des années dans nos établissements dans
des établissements
scolaires don son victimes des élèves de
confession juives et un certain nombre
d'entre eux ont d'ailleurs vu leur
famille faire le choix de les scolariser
dans le privé pour ces
raisonslà on a eu ces dernières heures
et ces derniers jours plusieurs alertes
qui sont remontées d'agression
d'intimidation qui ont eu lieu dans des
établissements s'appuyant sur la
situation internationale pour intimider
ou menacer des élèves de confession
juives je le dis c'est absolument
inadmissible et on sera intraitable j'ai
demandé hier qu'il y ait césine d'abord
j'ai demandé hier que systématiquement
quand il y a des faits de cette nature
ça remonte au ministère
systématiquement deuxièmement j'ai
demandé qu'il y ait systématiquement
saisine du procureur de la République
qu'il y ait plainte ou qu'il n'y ait pas
plainte le ministère saisira le
procureur de la République et pour avoir
échangé avec mon collègue Éric
dupontoretti et mon collègue Géral
d'Armin je peux vous dire que la
réactivité à la fois de la police et de
la justice seront au rendez-vous j'ai
l'occasion de montrer sur un autre sujet
qui est celui du harcèlement qu'après
avoir appelé un électrochoc on avait une
réactivité très forte aussi de nos
forces de sécurité et évidemment des
sanctions disciplinaires à l'endroit des
élèves donc je passe le message de
manière très claire je l'ai fait ce
matin des élèves qui intimideraient
menaceraient
ou envisagerait de le faire des
camarades des élèves de confession
juives devrait avoir peur il aurait de
bonnes raisons d'avoir peur parce qu'on
sera intraitable dans la réponse qu'on
apportera sur la deuxème question que
vous avez évoqué sur la neutralité
religieuse des accompagnateur de sortie
scolaire c'est un sujet je dois le dire
qui m'a beaucoup fait réfléchir parce
que d'un côté vous avez raison
c'est accompagne une activité qui se
déroule dans un on va dire un adre
scolaire puisque c'est des élèves qui
vont en sortie scolaire en même temps
ils ne sont pas dans
l'école et je sais que ça poser question
à beaucoup de monde ce qui a fini par me
convaincre c'est une tribune que j'ai lu
dans la presse qui date il y a quelques
années mais qui reste d'actualité je
vous en lis un extrait la tribune
s'appelle pour le droit des mares voilés
à accompagner les sorties scolaires je
vous lis le le résumé je ne pense pas
qu'il fait réglementer la tenue des
parents d'élèves comme celle des élèves
autant la loi de mars 2004 était tout à
fait nécessaire pour sortir du Cap à par
cas et sanctuirisé l'intérieur de
l'école autant il faut savoir faire
preuve de souplesse quand il s'agit de
parents et des sorties scolaires pour
une raison simple qui tient à une
certaine idée de la laïcité mais aussi
de l'école publique cette tribune elle a
été signée par Caroline Fourest qu'on ne
peut pas accuser a priori d'être dans la
relativisation de la laïcité que ce soit
à l'école ou dans la société et je vous
invite à lire ce texte qui est c'est sur
le H po c'est ce texte qui a achevé de
me convaincre donc autant j'ai une
détermination absolue et j'assume
totalement la décision que j'ai prise
sur l'application de la loi 2004 dans
l'école de la République qui a été
validée par le Conseil d'État qui s'est
prononcé sur le fond autant sur ce
sujet-là j'assume aussi la décision qui
est qui est la mienne qui est de ne pas
revenir sur les règles actuellement en
vigueur j'entends que ça puisse faire
débat qui des propositions différentes
qui viennent de groupes politiques mais
j'assume ma décision sur l'école sur le
Conseil des Sages évidemment j'ai
l'occasion de rencontrer dè ma
nominations la présidente Dominique
Schnapper évidemment le Conseil dest
sera rétabli dans toutes ses
prérogatives et son fonctionnement euh
même si je pense qu'il y a eu un certain
nombre de malentendu parce que je crois
pas qu'il a été qui a eu des volontés de
mon prédécesseur d'empêcher le Conseil
des Sages de de travailler
convenablement évidemment euh mais en
tout cas j'ai vu la présidente Dominique
Schnapper et je lui ai dit qu'évidemment
le Conseil pouvait s'autoaisir dès qu'il
le souhaitait et que le cœur de son
travail c'était l'application de la
laïcité euh dans l'éducation nationale
donc là de ce point de vue-là je vous
rassure j'ai répondu sur école rurale
sur école normale ça fait partie du
débat que j'aurai avec ma collègue de
l'enseignement supérieur on aura
l'occasion d'en discuter elle est quand
même très concernée comme vous avez vous
l'avez sous entendu dans votre
intervention sur le lien entre la
formation des maîtres et l'université
c'est un beau débat c'est un débat
nécessaire j'entends un certain nombre
de vos arguments d'autres me posent
davantage questions je pense que c'est
important qu'on ait cette réflexion on
leur avec les organisations syndicales
et au sein du gouvernement évidemment
avec les les
universités madame de La Provot on me
dit mon équipe me dit que je suis trop
long dans mes réponses qu'il y a
beaucoup d'interventions madame de La
provotter sur le S sur le 100 % e je
vais regarder les alertes que vous avez
formulé sur l'impact sur un certain
nombre d'acteurs
évidemment l'objectif
c'est de renforcer l'accès de nos élèves
à la pratique artistique et et à la
découverte culturelle et à l'éducation
artistique et culturelle donc on va
évidemment regarder les effets de bord
éventuels que vous avez évoqué sur le
bilan qu'on peut faire du passculture
collectif
euh à
l'école je pense que c'est très utile
parce que ça permet de donner un budget
pour réaliser des activités culturelles
pour les élèves je pense que ça mérite
c'est un dispositif qui mérite d'être
davantage mis en avant je me rends
compte qu'il y a beaucoup d'équipes
encore sur le terrain qui connaissent
pas forcément l'existence de ce
dispositif c'est quand même 25 € par an
par élève c'est ça pour faire des
activités donc voilà je pense qu'il faut
qu'on après il est probablement
perfectible donc on va y travailler
aussi euh j'ai vraiment de grandes
ambitions aussi sur ce sujet j'ai
l'occasion de le dire la culture
générale à l'école et notamment de
l'éducation artistique et culturelle je
pense qu'on peut aller plus loin
notamment dans le premier degré euh sur
la question des élèves scolarisés dans
les écoles hors contrat il y a
aujourd'hui environ 1900 écoles hors
contrat les 2/ers des élèves scolarisés
le sont dans le 1er degré et un/ers dans
le second degré vous savez que dans le
quinena précédent il y a un un nouveau
cadre juridique qui a été mis en place
euh pour mettre en œuvre ce nouveau
cadre juridique le nombre de contrôles a
très fortement euh augmenté on est passé
de 174 contrôles au cours de l'année
scolaire
2013-2014 à 668 pour l'année
2021-2000 22 les services veillent à ce
qu'aucun établissement ne puisse ouvrir
sans avoir été déclaré ou ou avant la
fin du délai euh d'opposition il y a un
suivi évidemment extrêmement extrêmement
fort sur la question euh de euh
l'empathie euh oui j'assume de dire
alors je sais pas si empathie est le
meilleur terme
euh l'altruisme le rapport à l'autre à
la différence à la tolérance la
bienveillance bref euh qu'on finalement
qu'on répondre à cette ambition de
Rousseau qui disait qu'on doit à la fois
instruire l'esprit et éduquer le cœur et
je pense que c'est aussi notre
responsabilité et quand on regarde les
pays qui ont réussi à faire reculer
massivement le harcèlement scolaire
c'est des pays qui ont massivement
investi aussi sur ces enjeux-là dès les
premières classes je suis allé au
Danemark mais il y a d'autres exemples
il y a par ailleurs des initiatives qui
existent et qui nous mon montre à quel
point c'est utile alors il y a la
méthode danoise qui est d'ailleurs
déployée dans des écoles à saint-toin ou
à Paris grâce au rectorat de Paris
notamment qui s'est beaucoup engagé sur
ce sujet-l il y a des établissements qui
appliquent d'autres méthodes je pense
notamment à ce qui est porté par le
philosophe réric Lenoir et la Fondation
sè les ateliers philo atelier à Visé
philosophique en primaire moi je crois
beaucoup à toutes ces initiatives donc
comment on va faire l'objectif et j'ai
saisi le Conseil supérieur des programme
c'est d'avoir un programme sur le sujet
pour le premier degré à la rentrée
prochaine 2024 et dès la rentrée janvier
2024 après les vacances qu'on est au
moins dans chaque département au moins
une école qui expérimente ces temps
d'apprentissage du rapport à l'autre du
respect de l'autre de l'empathie sur
l'ORD de techno voilà c'est ce qui a
permis il s'agit décision de mon
prédécesseur de ne pas surcharger le
l'agenda des l'emploi du temps des
élèves et donc pour avoir cette heure
supplémentaire de soutien
approfondissement en ma français la
mettre à la place de l'heure de
technologie bon c'est un choix qui a été
fait évidemment ça veut pas dire qu'on
renonce à nos ambitions sur la
découverte de la technologie et sur
l'apprentissage de cette discipline qui
est absolument essentielle y compris
pour être capable de comprendre les
enjeux aujourd'hui avec l'intelligence
artificielle et autres mais c'est pour
ça qu'on raisonne aussi par cycle et que
avant la 6è il y a déjà des initiations
qui sont mises en place évidemment après
il y a aussi beaucoup de choses qui sont
mises en place et qu'on veut continuer à
investir sur sur ce sujet euh monsieur
fialer je regarderai évidemment la
mission d'information qui avait le
rapport qui avait été remis sur la
culture citoyenne mais le président du
Conseil supérieur des programmes m'a dit
que l'équipe qui travaille sur les
propositions en matière de de de MC
s'appuyit aussi sur les travaux
parlementaires donc je pense qu'ils
s'appuyont sur ces travaux sur la
question effectivement augmentation de
la participation école privée j'ai eu
plusieurs saisines sur le sujet et donc
il faut qu'on a une réunion de travail
qu'on échange à la fois avec les
associations d'élus et évidemment les
représentants de l'enseignement privé
euh pour regarder comment est-ce qu'on
peut répondre à ces à ces à ces
préoccupations qui sont exprimées mais
je les ai entendu sur Madame casassbonne
sur le déploiement du plan du plan
harcèlement évidemment ça va nécessiter
une mobilisation de tous et euh partout
et je remercie aussi les sénateurs qui
se sont engagés sur le sujet j'avais
reçu Colette Méo qui n'est plus je crois
qui ne se représentait pas mais qui
avait fait un rapport un très bon
rapport sur le sujet aussi et on s'est
appuyé aussi sur ces travaux pour
avancer l'objectif c'est d'aller du vers
le 100 % prévention 100 % détection et
100 % réaction pour face au harcèlement
je vais pas revenir sur le contenu du
plan évidemment j'aurais à cœur qu'il
puisse se déployer aussi dans les
établissements français à l'étranger
mais qui je dois le dire d'ailleurs
souvent sont aussi un peu laboratoire
sur des dispositif hein sur la question
du harcèlement ou sur d'autres je me
suis rendu au au Danemark je le disais
où je suis allé dans le au lycée
français voilà ils avaient déployé des
initiatives donc euh voilà je j'essaie
de d'avancer plus rapidement pardon euh
sur la formation des aesh euh dans le
réseau des de l'enseignement français à
l'étranger euh à l'étranger c'est en
grande majorité la famille qui emploie
les aesh cependant le recrutement peut
se faire en collaboration avec
l'établissement euh le financement des
des aesh dans les établissements du
réseau euh français à l'étranger ne
relève pas de l'éducation nationale mais
les familles françaises ou binationales
qui recrutent et rémunèent un ou une àes
peuvent recevoir de la part de la EFE
une aide financière spécifique et c'est
le ministère de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères qui assure la tutelle vous le
savez sur la EFE demeurant on peut
réfléchir je pense effectivement avec le
ministère des Affaires étrangères euh et
la EFE a des euh actions de formation en
direction de ces personnels c'est
absolument nécessaire et là je pense
qu'on peut s'appuyer aussi sur des
choses qui ont été engagées pour
progresser en la matière pardon j'ai été
très long non c'était important le
zonage éducation prioritaire sera-t-il
revu ou pas c'était Sonia de la probeté
j'ai oublié zonage éducation prioritaire
oui à un moment donné il sera revu la
question c'est quand j'ai conscience que
beaucoup de plusieurs de mes
prédécesseurs vous ont fait cette même
réponse avant moi mais là on approche je
pense notamment parce que l'objectif
c'est aussi qu'il y ait une cohérence
avec la nouvelle carte des qpv qui doit
intervenir prochainement puisque vous
vous savez que la cartographie des
quartiers politiques de la ville
interviendra bientôt et je pense que
c'est important qu'on puisse faire le
travail en cohérence ensemble si on
appliquait aujourd'hui les critères
actuels de l'éducation euh enfin de la
cartographie actuelle et qu'on disait on
fait une actualisation sans ne rien
toucher au critères il y a 200
établissements qui rentreraient en
éducation prioritaire et 200
établissements qui en sortirai finement
c'est beaucoup plus simple d'en faire
rentrer que d'en sortir avec l'Impact
qu'on connaît d'autant qu'on a
énormément réinvesti dans l'éducation
prioritaire donc il y a un enjeu à la
fois d'interrogation sur les critères
qui permettent de relever de l'éducation
prioritaire et sûr dans le cas où des
établissements sortirai la manière dont
on accompagne cette transition mais euh
voilà c'est un sujet euh sur lequel je
vais avancer dans les prochains mois je
dis pas que la cartographie sera
actualisée dans les prochains mois mais
en tout cas je pense qu'à horizon 2024-
2025 on aura euh avancé sur ce sujet mes
chers collègues vous êtes encore
quelques-uns à vouloir poser des
questions je vais vraiment vous demander
parce qu'il est déjà